from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Mr Beast Burger in the UK and
the US this is food Wars
a Mr Beast Beast Alberta comes in double
and triple the B Star Burger in the UK
also comes in two sizes the double and a
triple it's a dripping grease holy shh
can you see how wet this is let's weigh
a triple Burger now to see whose Burger
is bigger look how gross these scales
are by the way the b-style triple in the
UK weighs 270 grams the US triple B
style burger weighs 290 grams
in the U.S Mr Beast Burger has one size
of crinkle cut fries they come in either
unseasoned or seasoned in the UK we also
just have one size of fries and they
come as either seasoned
or as unseasoned speaking of fries the
menu offers a Chris style burger who's
Chris his Burger has fries on it and for
this they charge you an extra dollar or
in the UK an extra British pound this
got me wondering how many fries come on
this burger and does that warrant an
extra dollar charge let's count and find
out
one two three
that seems reasonably generous 27 fries
on my Cristal Burger but what about the
cost of the fries let's count how many
fries coming in order one two three
can't do that one 92. let's go by volume
for an extra dollar you get 33 grams of
fries an order of fries total is 133
grams how do we figure that out you're
paying four Pence three per chip we had
33 grams equal a dollars
how much was it one pound 17 worth of
chips in the burger I think technically
you're paying like an extra pound for
this one compared to the Beast Burger
so you actually are you are getting
slightly more than you pay for
my 17p
so if our math is correct it looks like
I'm the Chris style burger per gram each
fry costs three cents but if you get the
crinkle cut fries and the side each fry
per gram costs 4 cents so you're
actually getting a better deal on fries
if you get them in the crisp burger then
separately that's pretty nice that took
way longer than it should have and I'm
sorry
here is everything you'll find at a Mr
Beast Burger in the UK here's everything
you can find in the US at a Mr Beast
Burger there's a slight problem with our
usual exclusives approach to this
section which is namely that the UK
doesn't have any everything on the menu
here is also available in the US however
I do have a suspicion that some of these
things might be slightly different so
we're going to take a look the only food
exclusive the US has over the UK is in
the US you can get a Mr Beast impossible
Burger made with the impossible beef
that's because at the time of recording
this impossible beef is not available in
the UK that's because it contains a key
ingredient called soy lehemoglobin AKA
heme according to Impossible Foods it's
what makes some Meats taste so meaty and
creates the bleeding effect PM is
classified as Gras generally recognized
as safe in the U.S however it does not
have regulatory approval in the UK or
the EU just yet although impossible
foods do say they're working on it
besides that the only drink again in the
US can't get in the UK is Sierra Mist UK
consider yourself lucky Sierra Miss
sucks
start down the same with the classic so
we have the Mr beasts style double two
smash patties there's cheese and then
there's also pickles chopped onions some
mustard and some ketchup I love Smash
Burgers and I wish more places did Smash
Burgers you end up with these incredibly
like crispy bits on the outside you see
this
that's just like pure flavor
it's like beef candy it's brilliant
it's really good
that's pretty good I do like this I
don't know if I would consider this a
smash Patty though tasty juicy then of
course we have the b style triple which
has the same toppings but an extra beef
patty a Chris style what up Chris
whoever you are fries and bacon and the
sandwich
yeah so it is just okay so this is the
UK Chris style burger we have bun we
have fries with some cheese two beef
patties and on the bottom just one piece
of bacon and it's kind of that like
cheap bacon I associate this with
buffets particularly when you go to an
all-inclusive resort in Central Europe I
have to try this one it looks so good
they didn't skimp on the fries this
thing is dense so this is the Carl's
Deluxe in the UK what they've done is
for some reason only flipped one of the
burger buns and then they kind of use
that to create a grilled cheese effect
which in the UK we call a cheese toasty
but then within that you have a beef
patty with cheese on both sides as well
as some grilled onions the Chandler
style there's nothing on this just
burgers and cheese like whose food is
made for like 10 year olds Chandler come
on man what's going on this is a very
very basic cheeseburger it's just bun
cheese meat
bun it just feels a little bit like when
you're a little kid and all you want is
a hamburger with bread and beef
it's too dry come on Chanda live a
little man get some sauce involved maybe
even some pickles who knows I don't know
what the Nashville tastes like over
there in the UK sticking Tenders in here
but this one
crunchy
and of course they also have the option
of just like a regular chicken sandwich
and weird way it kind of reminds me of
the McChicken but like not as flavored
any fast food place this would be like
the dollar menu chicken sandwich this is
nine dollars bro no no no no no no no no
no this is the Nashville
this is so offensive to the people of
Nashville
people of Nashville Look Away now
because the UK is about to start another
Revolutionary War so the problem is uh
in the UK no one really knows what
Nashville hot chicken is supposed to
look like so fast food chains can get
away with serving things like this and
people don't know enough to call them
out on it and what is this come on what
they've done as far as I can tell is
just take standard chicken tenders and
then I think they've added maybe some of
the seasoning from the seasoned fries
and then tried to pass that off as a hot
chicken sandwich
I'm not good with spice there's nothing
going on there zero scovilles that's not
Nashville nor is it hot you can also
just get a chicken tender sandwich I
don't understand what the difference is
particularly this one has pickles on it
I just wish we could up our chicken game
in the UK at the moment we're not doing
the best job of it and unfortunately Mr
Beast Burger is not our hero when it
comes to that so Carl making a second
appearance on the menu apparently as a
grilled cheese that is two tap buns
flipped over which you smashed in the
middle of it the six bucks oh this
that's really funny how much is a loaf
of bread and a bunch of slices of
American cheese you can make like 20 of
these this thing looks quite sad I think
both of the buns are supposed to be
flipped quite interesting aesthetic
the cheese hasn't really melted properly
so it's not stuck to this so it's just a
very smooth shiny layer of cheese is
your seasoned fries
no
it does give me like a slight Nando's
vibe to it in terms of the heat level
and some of the flavor profiles as well
like almost like a Peri-Peri seasoning
on this Mr Beast burger also offers
something called b style fries which
comes loaded with caramelized onions
American cheese pickles Mayo ketchup and
mustard this is it right here I don't
know about this guys maybe not the most
visually appealing however I like the
idea of fries and pickles together
cheers
I really like these these are really
good and one dessert
a chocolate chip cookie
it's a pretty good cookie that's not bad
this is like pretty stale obviously
we're a bit lacking and exclusives in
the UK but maybe I can take some
pre-existing menu items and combine them
to create a Harry style burger
trademark Harry Style the Chandler style
which was the very plain one I'm going
to take some of the fake Nashville Hot
Chicken which is not very hot at all
lamb that straight on top actually I
think this will benefit from some of the
moisture on this bun so I'm going to
keep that as well so we're going for Mr
Beast style fries because I quite liked
the crisp Style with the fries on it
here goes the Harry Styles
[Music]
you know what we might have done
something though I actually don't mind
the combination of chicken and beef I
think that kind of works oh god what
have I done they were too preoccupied
with whether or not they could they
didn't stop to think about whether or
not they should but honestly don't hate
it give it a try so for my signature
Burger here's what I'm gonna do I think
this is a really good idea I'm excited
about this I'm gonna take a Carl's
grilled cheese and a second Carl's
grilled cheese
and mine's gonna be the b style burger
but instead of buns it's two grilled
cheeses check this out grilled cheese
double patties should I put fries on it
too why not we'll make it a crisp style
because these fries have all the
seasoning and stuff on it they have all
the ketchup and all the sauces and
everything on it one has caramelized
onions too okay there they got the Beast
burger or the beef style burger this is
the Joe style burger we can also call
this I've been told they look like old
Mr Beast so this could be old Mr B style
burger or Mr Beast with no serotonin
burger or I kind of look like that guy
from Game of Thrones Burger so whatever
you want to call it but here we go oh
man this I'm like excited about this
look how good this looks
I'm an absolute genius this is so good
mmm oh man
hear me put this on the menu
put this on the menu one more
like I think I really want to keep
eating this I want to bite I'm sorry
[Music]
here's a USB style double burger combo
over here it will run you
15.29 that same combo in the UK is 14
pounds 99 15 quid for that yes
holy we own something none of it but
what about the delivery fees using the
Mr Beast Burger site in the U.S the same
combo with tax delivery fees and tip
costs
28.72 increasing the cost by 87.8
percent oof so if possible you may want
to go pick up your food it's a similar
deal here in the UK we checked this
order on deliveroo and they charge a two
pounds 49 delivery fee and a two pounds
and five pence service charge which
jacks the price up by almost a third one
big difference worth pointing out is the
Tipping culture in the UK and the US
it's much less common to tip in the UK
than it is in America in the UK If you
go to a restaurant for some food it's
usually common to give maybe a 10 or a
12.5 service charge if the service has
been good but you can't even opt out of
that if you don't want to pay it
particularly where delivery is concerned
I think tipping is even less common in
the UK I Got a notification actually on
my delivery app the other day to say
that six percent of people in my area
have been tipping their drivers recently
so that's six out of every 100 people
are tipping a delivery driver when I say
that we don't have as much of a tipping
culture in the UK it's not that we
really stingy we just generally have a
much higher minimum wage in the UK than
you do in the US so there's less
Reliance on tips to make ends meet for
service industry stuff
we thought we'd take a look back over
the story of Mr Beast Burger to give you
all some context it all started with a
YouTube video back in 2020 in which Mr
Beast opened a single drive-through
restaurant where the food is free and
customers would even get free money for
visiting obviously thousands of people
showed up and the video got over a
hundred million views at the end of the
video Mr Beast announced Mr Beast Burger
his chain of burgers which was available
across the U.S for delivery department
with virtual dining Concepts a platform
which matches brands with existing
restaurants and kitchens to prepare and
deliver food by using existing kitchens
Mr beastberg was able to expand rapidly
opening 300 locations in the US in the
first week followed by more in the UK
and Canada shortly after for context it
took McDonald six years to open 300 Us
locations you can start to see why
Brands love virtual kitchens at the time
of filming this there is only one brick
and mortar Mr Beast Burger location
recently opened in New Jersey's American
Dream mall at the Grand Opening over a
hundred thousand fans showed up some
waiting in line all all night it was a
massive success captured by Colin and
Samir who documented the entire day
according to the dock at the Grand
Opening Mr Beast Burger sold six
thousand two hundred and twelve burgers
and broke the world record by three
times Guinness world records has asked
for proof and at the time of this
recording has not made it official but
it has an opening sunshine and Roses
pretty much anybody can apply to become
a virtual kitchen for Mr Beast Burger
there's a form on the virtual dining
Concepts website where you can tell them
which facilities you have in the kitchen
so if you have a fryer a flat top and a
fridge and you normally make fried food
even if you just have a single location
you can cook Mr Beast Burger that's all
it takes a fryer a flat top and a fridge
I mean you can buy a deep fryer for
pretty cheap and I feel like you could
install a flat top on like pretty much
any kitchen and everyone's got a fridge
so I feel like I could probably cook Mr
Beast burger if I wanted to a wide
variety of restaurants acting as virtual
kitchens has led to a slew of quality
control issues for the chain the food is
coming from all types of restaurants
independent of each other so what you're
getting may be a bit of a crab shoot so
we went ahead and got
Mr Beast burger from a second location
first the Chandler style and that's a
say it looks pretty good right very
impressed the Chandler style from
restaurants
number two
okay the first thing I noticed is the
Burger's not wrapped
is that okay it's bigger but I mean that
clearly different bun this is more of a
smash Patty how it's like really like
almost like paper thin where this just
looks like tiny burgers Chandler burger
right
um
the cheese makes this one
[Music]
no it's like a different quality of meat
too
I think that this actually is pertinent
information this is from a restaurant in
Glendale this was from the Buca Di
beppos at Universal Studios
chicken sandwich all right again place
number one the place we like saying it's
Nashville but instead of doing chicken
sandwich and doing chicken tender
sandwiches bit of a disparity between a
and b
icy the plane there's no spice to that I
mean this one
yeah um
that however is much better despite some
of these quality discrepancies Mr Beast
Burger shows no sign of slowing down its
growth earlier this year Mr Beast
tweeted that the brand has already
shared over a hundred million dollars of
Revenue with restaurants Across America
when he says shared it means that not
all the money is going to Mr Beast nor
is all the money going to the
restaurants the restaurants will
obviously take a large cup but then some
of the money will go to Virtual dining
Concepts and I'm sure some of it is
going to Mr Beast as well for example
one restaurant in Dallas Texas claimed
it sold seven thousand dollars worth of
Mr Beast burgers in a single day Mr
Beast actually once described the launch
of Mr East Burger as a gamble but so far
it's looking like that gamble paid off
we actually collected today's order in
store and I had to kind of place the
order there by showing the guy my phone
and he kind of tapped it all through for
me he was actually kind of surprised at
how much the burgers cost he said they
looked quite expensive I guess it just
means that he wasn't aware of how many
fees are being added on so that either
the delivery platform or virtual dining
Concepts can get a fair cut of the
profit
it seems like the nutritional stats for
Mr Beast Burger are actually the same in
the U.S and the UK a b style with double
patties is 950 calories 66 grams of fat
23 grams of saturated fat 43 grams of
carbs 41 grams of protein and 1 840
milligrams of sodium note that is 80 of
your daily sodium make it a b style
triple and the calories go up to 1160
which is over half of your daily
allowance what you really have to look
out for here is the saturated fat a
b-style triple contains 150 percent of
your daily recommended intake bump it up
to a beast style double burger combo
with unseasoned fries and a can of
Sierra Mist gives you a grand total of 1
330 calories pop it up to a triple
and you hit
1540 calories comparing the b style
burger to other fast food chain Burgers
Mr Beast calorie wise lands about here
it's pretty high up there but good news
for Jimmy no one in America cares
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Red Bull and the UK and the US
this is food Wars
in the UK Red Bull comes in three
portion sizes a 250 milliliter can
a 355 milliliter can and a 473
milliliter can in the US our Red Bull
cans come in four
or 250 milliliters 12 fluid ounces or
355 milliliters 16 fluid ounces or 473
milliliters and the biggest one 20 fluid
ounces yo
or
591 milliliters that means our us
largest size is 30 percent bigger than
the UK's
if we're actually getting our 473
milliliters worth
actually looks slightly more than 473.
maybe we're getting even more for our
money the largest single item by volume
in the UK is a 24 pack of our 355
milliliter cans our total is 8520
milliliters which is around 288 fluid
ounces while we do have a larger cannot
offer that only comes as part of a 12
pack meaning that the total is only 5
664 milliliters Which is less than the
24 pack of this one in the US our
largest mobile item is a 24 pack of 12
fluid ounce cans I was unable to get my
hands on it
but is the same liquid amount as the
UK's largest our closest second is a 12
pack of 24 fluid ounce cans
hero all the Red Bull products you'll
find in the UK some of which you won't
find in the US here are all the Red Bull
items in the U.S you won't find in the
UK so technically we have eight Red Bull
products in the UK we have the normal
one we have the sugar-free one we have
the zero one red green yellow orange and
white some of these are seasonal and
we'll rotate in and out so it's a little
bit tricky to keep track of exactly
what's on offer but this is what we
could get today in addition to this we
have a couple of sugar-free exclusives
which technically adds to the total from
what I can tell these three flavors are
exclusive to the US and you can't find
them in the UK first we have the blue
Edition which is blueberry flavored and
we got the peach flavored which I
believe is flavored Peach and the winter
Edition which is what flavored fig Apple
now both countries have the coconut
flavor but from what I can tell online
we also have the coconut sugar free
flavor I actually couldn't even find
sugar-free versions of the red one or
the orange one I did find a sugar-free
yellow one though you can tell it's
sugar-free because it's got this blue
sugar-free band there
blue sugar-free label there and also the
tab is blue that's quite fun while it's
not technically a UK exclusive I did
find this one while I was hunting for
Red Bull I think it's imported from
Thailand and it's a cold brew coffee
flavored Red Bull which sounds pretty
intense because there aren't too many
exclusives between the US and the UK I'm
gonna do a lightning round of every
flavor I get my hands on here in the US
couldn't find any of the sugar-free
option but I know they are available at
least online and also I got Red Bull
Zero and sugar-free Red Bull so let's do
a quick lightning round of each flavor
ready the issue here is that I don't
drink energy drinks
I don't like the taste of Red Bull they
make me feel weird I drink tea if I need
a bit of a caffeine here and that's it
but apparently I have to taste test all
of these so wish me luck
I am not happy about this
regular Red Bull flavors but uh
sugar-free
I don't think I've ever had a sugar-free
one maybe I should because I did drink
an alarming amount of Red Bull when I
was younger and maybe a sugar-free
option would have been a good idea
you know
well side-by-side action
regular
sugar-free I might start getting the
sugar-free ones it's like really close
good job on that Red Bull
basically the only time I drink Red Bull
is when it's in a Jager Bomb
it's also
makes me think of those which is not the
vibe for a 11AM video shoot
cheers I guess so this is the normal Red
Bull
the best thing I can say about this is
that
The Taste kind of like disappears fairly
fast
so I'll uh
leave that in the middle to begin with
while I did the rankings
this is the sugar-free version
in the giant can
the aftertaste isn't quite as nice with
the sugar-free version
slightly worse than the regular one
sugar-free
has some sugar in I guess it says zero
grams of sugar and sugar free but for
some reason they got another one they
had zero sugar
okay
doesn't have much of a taste either to
be honest you get kind of like that like
energy drink like jolt you get when you
take a sip of an energy drink
the Red Bull Zero oddly doesn't have
that okay the coconut Edition coconut
Berry Red Bull
I've never seen a human being drink any
of these never in my life have I seen
anyone purchase one of these or drink
them up until me making this video I did
not know this existed
and I don't know why they exist still
let's find out all right coconut and
Berry Red Bull
a product nobody asked for
this coconut Berry Red Bull is
absolutely terrible that is absolutely
that is what it's like to drink
uh sunscreen
red one watermelon
actually don't hang up
that's not bad
my issue is I don't understand why they
settled on that as the taste of like
unsweetened unflavored Red Bull because
it's not good
in my opinion watermelon has helped that
out the green Edition the dragon fruit
as you are aware dragons are green so
clearly the can is green dragon fruit
ever to make that connection
oh my God
it's somehow worse than this one it's
somehow worse
this is what I think pea tastes like
does that make sense it smells like pee
the energy that Red Bull gives you is
being counteracted by the absolute
depression these flavors are giving me
right now I'm like having this weird
thing about all this energy and it's
being converted into sadness because of
these two next up is the green one which
is flavored with cactus fruit
I don't know what cactus fruit is meant
to taste like if I saw a green can I
would assume maybe green apple or lime
it's fine I don't think it's quite as
good as the watermelon
watermelon Red Bull uh I don't want to
do this anymore
we're making a comeback watermelon's not
bad
watermelon's not bad
oh yeah baby the Red Bull meter is going
up
sugar-free tropical fruits
I generally quite like tropical fruits
flavored things because I have a palette
of a child
I spoke too soon that's really gross
no but worst one so far worse than the
sugar-free normal one all right blue
Edition
blueberry
get up at tart wow tart
38 grams of sugar in this you would not
think you would not believe that in the
way this tastes
I guess not complaining it's just do you
want your energy drink to be tart
regular tropical fruits one thing I'm
already noticing is that the sugar-free
versions have much less of a strong
smell compared to the versions with
sugar it's better than the sugar-free
version
still not great
a little more time
the regular tropical version is actually
better than unflavored Red Bull whereas
the sugar-free one something's gone
wrong there because that is actually
worse than the classic red bull all
right Peach Edition Peach nectarine here
we go
hmm
yeah wow
oh that's good that's really good also
tart
38 grams of sugar
the summer edition apricot strawberry I
mean that sounds lovely this maybe
sounds like the most appealing of any of
them so far so I've got high hopes
smells pretty good I get notes of
strawberry
[Music]
thank you
okay
see this is concerning because I didn't
actually want to like any of these this
is a problem guys I can't become a rebel
guy I'm not ready for a Red Bull era
I'm too loyal to Mercedes
this is pretty good
I definitely like I get apricot and
strawberry from that it's not
overpowering
just like a sort of nice sparkling River
that's yeah that's the best one I've
tried so far
winter Edition fig Apple
fig Apple winter I'm not making the
connection
um
not good it tastes like um
if um a sour apple Jolly Rancher was a
drink does that make sense
no not refreshing at all the coconut and
Berry Edition
I'm not getting much if any of the berry
flavor from this
Coconut's definitely the uh the star of
the show but it's not bad coming from
someone who like I said doesn't usually
like coconut as a flavoring I think it's
actually it's better than the tropical
as far as I'm concerned and last on the
flavor train we got the yellow Edition
tropical ooh tropical
oh it doesn't smell very good just
please be at least
[Music]
yeah okay
yeah it's all right okay and then last
but by no means least we have this
random imported coffee one that I found
my only concern or I guess comment on
this one is that I'm not sure who the
target audience is because I feel like
if you like coffee or just drink coffee
if you want a caffeine hit I'm not sure
why if you liked coffee you would want
to flavor your Red Bull with coffee
because you're already getting the
caffeine but here you're just getting
like loads of sugar and additives as
well
it tastes like someone has taken
a coffee and poured Coca-Cola in it
which
might be to your liking it's the spot
the I want to Jack my caffeine level
through a roof spot I actually where
would that go is that better than
regular red bull
[Music]
if you don't think it is
but is it the worst one I've had today
[Music]
no no it's not that's there
that's there
and we're done
my vision is starting to blur
oh uh this might this might have been a
bad idea oh no no
it's kicking in
I like Red Bull sugar-free is exactly
the same thing this one had less of an
aftertaste which actually I didn't
really like coconut and dragon fruit
uh suntan lotion NP uh watermelon I
liked
blue a little too tart
Peach I enjoyed fig Apple trash
and a tropical not bad my main takeaways
from that uh firstly I need to lie down
we can make that happen that would be
great secondly I think the sugar-free
versions are overwhelmingly like worse
tasting than the sugar versions are I
also think for me like I say I don't
love the taste of just normal Red Bull
so I think I've ended up liking the ones
which are flavored with things which
aren't Red Bull so that makes sense
foreign
what about the price well in the UK a
250 milliliter can will cost you 1 pound
50 at a Tesco Supermarket that works out
to roughly 60 Pence per 100 milliliters
which is around 74 cents in the US the
cost of this 250 milliliter Red Bull can
at Walmart is two dollars and 18 cents
which breaks it down to 80 cents per 100
milliliters so it looks like the UK is
actually getting a slightly better deal
on its Red Bull than the US's that's
actually kind of a food Wars first so it
doesn't happen often
in the UK our standard Red Bull contains
the following ingredients water sucrose
glucose acidifier citric acid taurine
sodium carbonates and magnesium
carbonate caffeine niacin pantothenic
acid vitamin B6 vitamin B12 flavorings
colors caramel and riboflavin and carbon
dioxide our Red Bull in the U.S contains
pretty much the same stuff carbonated
water sucrose glucose citric acid
taurine sodium bicarbonate magnesium
carbonate caffeine
calcium
[Music]
Pantheon tape
pyroxtonite HCI
vitamin B12 natural and artificial
flavors all right the vitamins have
different names but it's all the same
you might notice the ingredient taurine
on that list now taurine has been the
subject of inaccurate rumors on the
internet for years taurine has an
association with Bulls drawing its name
from the Latin word for bull Taurus some
people run with this and falsely claim
that it's code for bull semen the name
actually comes from the fact that
taurine was first isolated from oxbile
okay the good news is that there's no
oxfit in Red Bull as food producers have
used a synthetic version of taurine it
isn't derived from animals also means
that Red Bull is suitable for vegans one
study found that exposing human teeth to
energy drinks for 15 minutes four times
a day resulted in a significant and
irreversible loss of tooth enamel the
study also noted that energy drinks were
twice as harmful as regular soft drinks
to tooth enamel as the study in rats
found chronic intake of Red Bull may
cause a decline in kidney function
however these results have not been
replicated in human studies but any
excuse to see my boys are dancing rats
Rebel in the UK contains 110 calories
per 250 milliliter can one of these cans
also contains 27 grams of sugar
according to their website this is
actually a similar amount of sugar to
what you might find in say apple juice
both sugar-free Red Bull and Red Bull
Zero contain 10 calories per this 8.4
fluid ounce can sugarfleet flea
sugar-free replace their sugar with
acid flame potassium and aspartame Red
Bull Zero Place sugar with
acyl thin potassium K and Sucralose also
sulfame potassium or SK which is Red
Bull's zero calorie sweetener has had a
share of controversy over the years
although to be fair a lot of the studies
this came from were done in the 1970s
this has led to their validity being
called into question in recent years
according to healthline.com in 1996 the
Center for Science in the public
interest urged the FDA to do more
testing on acek before allowing its
inclusion in soft drinks the cspi go on
to say that there are health concerns
associated with ask including cancer
hormone disruption and risks to pregnant
people
also study that determine the chronic
use of acek and male mice was linked to
possible changes in brain function over
a period of 40 weeks yeah I believe that
it's been 40 minutes and my brain is
just
one of the perceived benefits of
drinking Red Bull is that it's supposed
to give people a boost through its
caffeine content a 250 milliliter can
contains 80 milligrams of caffeine but
is that a lot compared to other soft
drinks yeah a 12 ounce can of Coke
contains 34 milligrams of caffeine
that's less than half the amount of
caffeine and almost double the amount of
fluid as this Red Bull a 12 ounce can of
Mountain Dew contains slightly more with
55 milligrams if we compare Red Bull to
another popular energy drink Monster
you'll find that they actually have the
same caffeine content per 100
milliliters which is 32 milligrams
although monster cans tend to be bigger
so you are getting more caffeine in
total the caffeine amount however can be
a bit underwhelming when compared to
regular coffee and eight ounce 237
milligram brewed coffee contains on
average 95 milligrams of caffeine and a
double shot of espresso contains 125
milligrams one issue comes from the fact
that some people will consider Red Bull
to be more like a soda and therefore
might drink higher quantities of it so
is it possible to overdose on Red Bull
uh yeah although highly unlikely
caffeine related dads have been found in
individuals that intake somewhere
between three and five grams not
milligrams grams of caffeine in one day
that would be 40 of these I feel like
your bladder would explode first
although apparently that wasn't enough
caffeine for some people in 2014 Red
Bull were sued in a class action lawsuit
around false advertising remember the ad
campaign Red Bull gives you wings well
it doesn't false advertisement back then
Red Bull did say in its marketing they
that this drink could improve
concentration and reaction speeds a
claim that lacked any scientific support
furthermore the suit said that Red Bull
persistently and pervasively Market
their product as a superior source of
energy worthy of a premium price over a
cup of coffee or other sources of
caffeine Red Bull did agree to a 13
million dollar settlement which granted
anyone who purchased a Red Bull dating
back to January 1st 2002 was entitled to
10 or 15 worth of Red Bull from calorie
count to portion sizes we wanted to find
out all the differences between movie
theater food at AMC and Odeon movie
theaters in the UK and the US this is
food Wars
[Music]
it might seem like Odeon and AMC are
different chains however they're
actually owned by the same company so
let's compare popcorn or the UK Odeon
Cinema comes in four sizes as a kids
regular
medium and large classic popcorn at a US
AMC comes in three sizes small regular
large and of course if you want to get a
to-go option they have the
AMC Mega bear bag
boom that's three times the size of the
standard large let's wear a large Salted
Popcorn in both countries to see whose
large is bigger so our largest little
popcorn is actually I think come to 204
grams which is about 30 grams more than
we were supposed to get
194 grams of popcorn Avatar haven't seen
it and for my own morbid curiosity so
I'm gonna weigh it in the bag I don't
know just subtract like two grams how
much could the bag weigh this
and 20 grams drinks at a US AMC Theater
come in three sizes small 20 fluid
ounces regular 32 fluid ounces and a
large Avatar 44 fluid ounces now
shockingly our drinks in the UK are
actually just as big as the US ones for
once Cinemas I think are the only place
in the UK where you can get a drink of
this size the thought of getting one of
these from a fast food place in the UK
is absolutely unheard of let's measure
out the large in both countries to see
if we're getting as much as we've been
promised wow it's pretty close what was
it supposed to be 44 by my calculations
they've pretty much nailed bang on the
40 ounce line so you're maybe not
getting quite as much as you were
promised admittedly we did lose a little
bit in transit and also a little splash
just on the table there so maybe you
could round it up generously to like
4142 which honestly even if it's
slightly less near being promised I
think we can forgive them certainly we
can't fault James Cameron for this
certainly we can't blame the navi of
Pandora
we also have ice drinks which are the
ICONic Tango ice blasts we have them in
three sizes a regular a medium and a
large Tango ice blasts are amazing they
have a bit of a cult following in the UK
I think like Cinema goes over here
really really love these you can get
them usually in two flavors which are
red and blue I don't know exactly what
they're supposed to taste of it's kind
of just like Tangy food coloring anyway
they're not supposed to look like this
as you can probably tell these are just
been sat out under the studio lights for
a while here's what they're supposed to
look like you can also get ice beverages
at the usamc primarily in the form of an
AC and they come in three sizes normally
but not at the AMC we went to they only
had regular it should be a small 20
fluid ounce the regular Avatar way of
the water Navi colored drink here is a
32 fluid ounce and of course the large
is a 44 fluid ounce I think that's the
exact same size as the soft drinks we
just had I would like to request I don't
know how hard this is going to be if
Yuli and the rest of the post-production
team can make it look like I'm in the
underwater Avatar
with like me just swimming with the navi
right we I'm in the movie how hard would
that be can make it 3D as well that's
pretty easy right do you have that done
by end of day Friday when I'm swimming
around with Jake Sully
here is everything you'll find in the UK
Odeon Cinema that you won't find in an
AMC here's everything at a US AMC you
won't find at an Odeon we'll start with
the classic which is popcorn in the UK
it comes in two flavors a salted or
sweet you can also ask them to mix them
together for you salt and sweet
excellent contrast you won't find butter
popcorn anywhere on the menu in the UK
the fact that you guys are putting
melted butter and popcorn extremely
weird to us stop doing that
in the U.S a popcorn obviously comes
plain or salted but we also have butter
popcorn and yes Harry we like to put
melted butter all over our popcorn two
things I want to know one it's almost
always referred to as butter flavored
topping presumably because they can't
legally call it butter or maybe they're
just other junk in there and it isn't
officially butter in America there's
just some people who are so nuts about
the butter AMC now has something I don't
know if this is to go you get this in
the theater where they give you no joke
this thing of butter on the side to take
into the theater with you because
there's so much butter flavor topping
drama in the U.S AMC was like here just
take this and go to go do it yourself
well look at that you see that you see
that oh yeah yeah once I want you to pay
attention now imagine I'm eating this in
the dark oh I lick my butter so much
in my house
this is like the messiest snack in the
world
I never get Butternut popcorn this is so
gross
foreign
it has like a buttery flavor to it yeah
it's definitely flavored butter that's
not melted butter you can also get
sweets as a topping on your popcorn in
the UK this comes in the form of
Cadbury's dairy milk buttons has
Smarties Kit Kats and Rolos speaking of
popcorn you can also get cheddar popcorn
which is I don't know if this is just
none of your theaters really popular in
the UK at all but it's popcorn and it's
tossed in like cheese dust and also
caramel corn which is popcorn you
guessed it encased
and caramel
there's a range of hot food options at a
UK Odeon Cinema including the following
firstly we have the iconic Cinema Hot
Dog now obviously you guys have hot dogs
in America however
it's an exclusive because ours is a pork
sausage while yours I think is beef that
looks real sad oh no
oh hot dog yay that's pretty good size
hot dog right
movie theater hot dogs for some reason
are really good you notice that movie
theaters and ball games that's where the
hot dog's absolute best next up we have
two Pizza options at UK Odeon Cinemas
you can get a cheese pizza or a
pepperoni pizza I haven't even opened
them and I'm losing my mind because this
is how they've been packaged and
presented to us
foreign
[Music]
I'm slightly at a loss for words
I might be giving them too much credit
here I think maybe if this were fresh
out of the oven which obviously this is
not it actually might be okay but
there's a reason why pizza boxes exist
for example maybe look into that in
future I'm just imagining any Italian
viewers watching this and just crying
it's like a flat bread pizzas the MCA
went to did not currently have them
because I went there right when they
opened they weren't ready yet but you
can get also a four cheese a pepperoni
or a supreme flatbed Pizza you also get
yourself curly fries now we're talking
early fries right hmm
The Impossible nuggets
oh yes for some reason I picked the
marinara let's do it who doesn't want to
eat
fake deep fried Meats
dip it in a red sauce in a pitch dark
theater
nope oh wow those are really bad we have
pretzel bites at our AMC you can get
them unsalted with cheese salted with
cheese which I got
garlic parmesan with cheese everything
bagel with cheese and cinnamon sugar
with icing
they don't tastes bad but I grew really
chewy
you're gonna want those right out of the
oven or the microwave you can also get a
Bavarian Legend pretzel the theater we
went to do not have them at the time of
filming this at a UK Odeon you can get
triple dip nachos which are tortilla
chips which come with guacamole salsa
and I think a cheese sauce this is how
it came what we have is just a bag of
plain tortilla chips and a box labeled
dips we have the cheese sauce we have
some very vibrant guacamole
it's like someone Blended up Shrek we
have some tomato salsa gelapenos
think this was onion and chive dip maybe
I feel like I have to try and assemble
these somehow I want to do it in a way
but hopefully you guys can uh
join me along for the ride because it
could be interesting I want to try and
get some like layerage going on there if
possible
oh God
oh no
okay I thought that all came out as one
brick but there were actually two pots
in there thank God go on
there you go look at that queso
okay now we're gonna hit it with some
salsa
[Music]
recently
I think this has gone sensationally well
this is
this is nachos right here
some people might say Harry
do you want to heat these up
I'd say no it doesn't need it perfect
the way they are
man look at the color on this
no my mum used to like the nachos she's
not dead should I come into the cinema
with her in a while
there huh
they don't look terrible right
absolutely disgraceful I don't know
what's going on that island of yours but
your nachos thumbs down I would say
pretty generous with the chips not bad
right these are UK level nachos right
here I don't know who
is like oh yeah perfect this is exactly
what I think nachos are do they make a
mistake if I look at this right they
gave us a thing of marinara sauce I'm
assuming this marinara is supposed to be
salsa can you imagine because you just
get this and go to the theater in the
dark if you're watching a movie oh man
man this salsa sure isn't very chunky oh
well man I cannot wait to eat these
nachos oh I'm so worried about the Tree
of Life Avatar too
oh
like what the hell it's so bad it's like
oddly alluring does that make sense
this is terrible I'm sorry I'm gonna do
everyone a favor and throw this out
yuck come run to the sides we have a
couple of side options in the UK that
you won't find in the US unfortunately
one of them we couldn't find today which
are crisper fries which are kind of like
very thin slices of potato which are
fried however we could get our hands on
these chicken strips it's actually
pretty good technically also included on
the sides menu are the dips so that
includes basically everything that you
would normally find on the nachos
including the side of jalapenos the
salsa dip the cheese the guacamole and
this cream cheese garlic and herb dip we
have one pre-packaged popcorn option if
you don't fancy the fresh stuff which is
this
toffee popcorn I think this is kind of
more similar to what you guys might
expect from like caramel corn in the U.S
it's basically popcorn but with an
actual coating of this kind of like
sugary syrupy stuff now the AMC has a
bunch of snack options that you won't
find in the UK starting with these known
as lifestyle snacks I'm assuming they're
meant to be a little bit healthier
starting all the way down here you have
the Planters sweet and salty trail mix
grass-fed beef jerky courtesy of country
Archer I don't know about this Rhythm
organic white cheddar cauliflower bites
wow no thanks
home free chocolate chip cookies you got
only three grams of sugar for the smart
and sweet watermelon bites mango sweet
and tangy super snacks dried mangoes and
skinny dipped dark chocolate almonds in
addition to the popcorn we also have
some sweets and chocolates which I will
go through now wine gums do you guys
have wine gums in the U.S I really like
these they're a bit of an old person
sweet I still don't know exactly why
they're called wine gums because I don't
think they have wine in them on top of
the gummies themselves they will have
like the name of a wine kind of stamped
on on their different colors the flavors
change according to the color red one's
always the best of course a couple of
Cadbury dairy milk options we have some
Cadbury caramel dairy milk nibbles dairy
milk giant buttons Galaxy minstrels so
in the UK we have dairy milk which is
owned by Cadbury and then the Mars
Corporation has their own van of milk
chocolate which is called Galaxy and
this is basically Galaxy chocolate with
a hard shell on the outside these
honestly are really good Cadbury 12
bites it's Cadbury dairy milk chocolate
and it's kind of got this weird like
swirled texture on the inside so it
lends itself to being quite like a flaky
and almost like melt in your mouth
chocolate bar they're pretty good Arrow
peppermint bubbles it's got this weird
like aerated texture in the middle which
is designed basically to melt in your
mouth when you eat it milky bar buttons
I loved milky bar as a kit it's
basically white chocolate which I used
to love when I was younger I think as my
palette has kind of evolved as I've
gotten older I don't really tolerate
white chocolate like I used to but these
are great a bit of a Nostalgia factor
and the last one we found today was
maltesers I love a malteser I still
don't fully understand what they are to
be honest what is the middle bit it's
not honeycomb but it's got like a
crunchy almost honeycomb texture now
it's not a pre-packaged option but it is
a sweet option we have pick and mix cups
in the UK pick and mix is like a really
iconic British thing I think it's
basically this notion of you go into a
sweet shop or in this case a cinema and
they'll have lots of different pots or
tubs of individual candies and you can
go in with a scoop scoop a few put them
in and create your own mixture of them
so if there's one particular one that
you love you can just have a cup full of
that or you can go for some variety mix
it up a little bit like we've done today
the issue is when you're layering it
you end up just going one layer of thing
at a time I haven't assembled this very
well couldn't get everything just
grabbed a bunch of stuff that they'll
look pretty good
also I think some Classics here Milk
Duds Junior Mints The Big Box
mini Snickers hey
Skittles my teeth are already starting
to hurt Butterfingers unwramped Minis
and
Sour Patch Kids and also Airhead
extremes this of course just the tip of
the iceberg you can get so so many
candies at an AMC
yeah this many
you can also get a Ben Jerry's milkshake
what they do is they let you choose
three scoops of ice cream of your
choosing and then pretty much just blend
them together to create a milkshake also
in the US we have ice cream you can't
get in the UK and get yourself a dibs
crunch a Haagen-Dazs bar Almond and
Nestle tohas ice cream sandwich and a
Nestle's drumstick the other soft drink
exclusives are actually aimed more at
children we have some fruit shoots to
come either as this one which is Apple
and blackcurrant or as Orange it's just
kind of like a bottle of squash and for
the Americans who might not know what
squash is uh does cordial help at all
you get like a concentrated juice and
then dilute it with water to produce
basically this the main event as far as
I'm concerned when it comes to drinks
are these ones which are the alcoholic
options you can get alcohol at UK
Cinemas we got a few of the things on
offer today and these include this
recorder leg strawberry and lime cider
we have a bottle of Heineken beer we
have some wine options we've got a
little bottle of red hair it's really
cute it's literally just like they've
taken a full-size bottle of red and just
squished it and scaled it down you can
also get white wine and I think rose
wine as well or if you're in a
celebratory mood
get a little bottle of Prosecco then we
have some pre-mixed cocktail options
today we got a classic GNT and
a Jack and Coke what about the beverage
in the Eos we have so so many beverages
starting with the coke freestyle the
freestyle machine you've seen it before
it has all of these flavors
I wasn't getting one of each you can
also get a Gold Peak unsweetened iced
tea which they did not have a Gold Peak
sweet tea which they also did not have
and minimated orange juice and Minuteman
apple juice
chocolate milk Dasani water Smart Water
and a Costa Coffee I also didn't have
that
I really got some coffee I've been told
that it is interesting that we can get
close to coffee here it is actually a
British coffee chain but it was bought
by Coca-Cola in 2019 for almost 4
billion pounds and has now begun
expanding into the US
a large Salted Popcorn of the UK Odeon
contains the following
863 calories
48.37 grams of fat of which 37.84 grams
of saturated
92.18 grams of carbs of which 5.94 grams
of sugars and an unknown amount of
sodium unfortunately the website didn't
have the sodium information I did reach
out via the live chat function and the
guy said they didn't know what had gone
on he was going to look into it for me
but I did not hit back a regular plain
popcorn popped in canola oil is 550
calories 24 grams of fat 2 grams of
saturated fat 74 carbs 1 380 milligrams
of sodium the same size popcorn but this
time cooked in coconut oil
540 calories 24 grams of fat 17 grams of
saturated fat 74 grams of carbs and
1380 milligrams of sodium now there are
no stats for the butter flavor tapping
which is a bit concerning but if you add
butter and salt to pretzel bites it adds
100 calories and 12 grams of fat 7 grams
of saturated fat 300 milligrams of
sodium
adding that same amount of butter to
this large Avatar way of the water
popcorn which is cooked in canola oil
you get
970 calories 51 grams of fat 10 grams of
saturated fat popcorn in my throat 117
carbs of which one gram of sugars and 2
450 milligrams of sodium same exact size
of popcorn but this time cooked in
coconut oil and the butter topping from
before that's 960 calories 50 grams of
total fat 35 grams of saturated fat 117
carbs of which one gram of that is
sugars and the sodium
2450 milligrams people of the internet
canola oil has slightly more calories
but way less saturated fat
a large sweet popcorn in the UK contains
the following
1790 calories
73.08 grams of fat of which 55 grams are
saturated 253 grams of carbs of which
84.04 grams of sugars and again an
unknown amount of sodium
gotta watch out for the caramel corn
newly this caramel corn in this size
bucket
1620 calories 64 grams of fat 21 of
those are saturated fat 510 grams of
carbs and of that 404 of those grams of
sugar
3190 milligrams of sodium now the large
cheddar corn seen here 1 620 calories
144 total grams of fat 21 of those are
saturated 68 grams of carbs and 2
470 milligrams of sodium
what about the most calorific thing on
the UK menu well that would be a large
sweet popcorn
with the topping option of dairy milk
giant buttons this combination would
come to a total of 2004 calories 85.08
grams of fat 62.2 grams of saturated fat
275.8 grams of carbs of which
106.44 grams are sugars that is just
over 100 of your daily calories 109 of
your daily fat 311 of your daily
saturates and 212 of your daily sugar
jeez so in the US our AMC menus vary I
did find a PDF that a bunch of stuff
listed on here I don't know how common
it is at AMC's but it is the Bavarian
Legend pretzel
with the cheese cup and mustard that
pretzel and mustard and cheese total is
1920 calories one thing I wanted to
point out is that
7600 milligrams of sodium that is
330.4 of your daily sodium intake hey
don't eat that pretzel
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Cinnabon in the US and the UK
this is Foods
[Music]
in the UK cinnabon's classic rolls come
in four portion sizes as a single as a
two pack as a four pack
and our largest size
a six pack in the US Cinnabon classic
rolls come in three sizes the single oh
my God
dang at the four pack for you and let's
be honest just you and then you can get
yourself a six pack this has some weight
to it
Cinnabon in the US also offers catering
sizes that you can't get in the UK that
means we can also get our classic
cinnamon rolls in a nine pack catering
tray put that on the screen ah
that's 50 larger than UK's biggest pack
[Music]
but is there a difference in the size of
the rolls themselves we're going to
weigh a classic Cinnabon in both
countries to find out
you can get Bond bikes in the UK but
unfortunately the store I went to didn't
have them this morning if you can get
them then they should come in a pack of
four in the US you can get van bites in
a pack of four
16 or the catering tray of 36. this is
nine times bigger than the UK's four
pack
four get a life UK Cinnabons also offer
mini bonds these come in three portion
sizes as a single as a six pack
or a larger size
as a 15 pack
use these as like a doorstop thicker
stale
over here our mini bands bands come in
portions of one
nine
fifteen and of course we have a catering
tray of 20. what about the drinks in the
UK we can get hot drinks in two sizes as
a regular which is 12 fluid ounces or a
large which is 16 fluid ounces in the US
our hot beverages come in four sizes
small regular large and this big
catering bag
or does it
because they forgot those three the more
observant among you would have noticed
that the UK's large is only the regular
over here we can also get ice drinks in
the UK but they just come in the same
sizes as our hot drinks 12 and 16 ounces
the sizes change a little when you
choose the ice drinks in the US they get
the small and the regular and the
catering size again the more observant
of you would notice that there are some
beverages missing from this cup Joe must
have started drinking that earlier
had a major beverage spilling mishap
with a delivery here
more on that later the final things to
compare are the toppings and sauces in
the UK you can get some additional
toppings like the cream cheese and the
pecans and they just come in the one
size
these little cups in the US we can get
extra frosting as a regular side of the
cream cheese frosting I mean
a whole pint
of the frosting
a side of pecans who cares let's weigh
the largest frosting side in each
country to find the difference
it's like barely moved so this is eight
of their frostings soon to be seven
described as cream cheese ambient
Korean cheese that sounds like a a
really experimental music genre
it's pretty cool you probably wouldn't
have heard of it but yeah I listened to
mostly cringey's ambience
here are all the Cinnabon items from the
UK that you won't find in the US here's
a Cinnabon menu you will not find in the
UK to start off with we have some bun
varieties you actually won't find in the
US let's start down here with choco buns
so as far as I can tell choco buns are
pretty much just their standard rolls
maybe with like a little bit of
chocolate powder sprinkled into the mix
but then also they are covered in
chocolate sauce
yes
our next exclusive roll is a Lotus
Biscoff bun long time viewers of the
show will know that I don't really like
Lotus Biscoff I didn't realize how
passionately the crew felt about Lotus
Biscoff because I'm now taking heat for
this um apparently it's because I don't
like coffee and they're really good with
coffee I just drink tea so maybe it's
wasted on me again look
Udu it's fine just not for me too sweet
for me and then finally because we're
actually shooting this on Valentine's
Day we can get a limited edition
Valentine's bun
all of our exclusive buns can also be
purchased in all three forms which is
the regular size the bond bytes and the
mini bonds we actually don't have any
exclusive barns in the US we can only
get the classic and caramel pecan Vans
both of which are obviously available in
the UK but we do have some other
exclusives to showcase the first one the
churro swirls
they forgot them
but here's what they look like
and I would love to have tried them now
we don't have turo swells but we do have
something called sinner chips which are
like small crunchy pieces of cinnamon
roll I'm not sure
if crunchy is what I want from my
cinnamon roll
they are crunchy they won't kill them
and these aren't doing it for me they're
really kind of dry and a little bit
burned almost
so you kind of get that like acrid burn
taste
which cancels out pretty much any
benefits that you get from the cinnamon
sugar
we also have something called center of
the Roll which Cinnabon has trademarked
in the US now here's what I'm assuming
this is by looking at it what it looks
like they just took Cinnabons
and like
mash them up or like unraveled them
and put them in a cup and this is smart
because the only thing I think keeping
everyone from getting a Cinnabon at the
mall is just kind of a pain in the butt
to eat and I think Cinnabon noticed this
and they responded with this like you're
right we'll just we'll just rip it up
put it in a cup and have at it
this works well I don't want to mess
with the classics
if you want to
sit down and have a Cinnabon it's a food
court go for it but
if you're on the move just get one of
these oh yeah
oh yeah
oh I forgot
oh I forgot I'm shooting a video right
now this is the that was the regular and
this is the caramel pecan bun we have a
near equivalent here but we call it roll
on the go as far as I can tell it's
pretty much just the same thing it's a
small cup of I think just the center
pieces of cinnamon rolls I'll come in
two flavors classic or choco I do think
my favorite part of a cinnamon roll is
the gooey little bit
see if this holds up
this is pretty good
decent amount of frosting they could
maybe have given you slightly more
frosting because I think there's some
like drier bites in the middle but
pretty good in the US we also have
cookie Barn bites
these are chocolate chip cookies with
cinnamon rolls inside of I'm just
finding this out right now chocolate
chip cookies with cinnamon rolls inside
of them yo straight up when I saw this
I'm like who's getting cookies at
Cinnabon this has this cannot have a
cinnamon roll so
even know this existed are you you got
that you got that yeah
look at look what's inside of it oh my
God that's crazy the other thing was was
this Cookie's pregnant with a Cinnabon
yeah
better an idea than execution
we also have Cinna sweeties which look
like mini Donuts that I'm assuming
oh wait I think this has a frosting
inside we've done these for Taco Bell
the Cinnabon Delights and I'm pretty
sure this filled with some sort of like
cream cheese right what are you talking
there's not
it's not cream cheese in these the
blanks the UK Cinnabon website also
advertises that some of their branches
will have Carvel brand ice cream as an
option but unfortunately we didn't have
that other one we went to now we're on
to the sauces and toppings in the US we
have a side of Oreo pieces
you can get a top of your barn there it
is we also have the eight ounces of
frosting and we also have clothes
this right here is you get a side of the
caramel frosting
that's also really good we only have the
one exclusive topping option here in the
UK and it's this one the Lotus Biscoff
crumb
in the interest of furnace I'm going to
try it again
it's just fine it's just fine
maybe with a coffee but
still not for me sorry guys
next up we got drinks ah finally I'm
dying a thirst we have coffee obviously
and you can also get yourself a hot
chocolate let's check out their hot
chocolate I mean it looks like hot
chocolate and let me see
wow actually not that good
skip that we actually have a better
range of hot drinks in the UK including
pretty much a full range of espresso
drinks including an Americano a
cappuccino a latte a mocha and so on we
can also get a tea and a hot chocolate
you can also customize the hot drinks
with a range of syrups including
cinnamon spice toasted marshmallow
salted caramel and more although if you
put any of those in a cup of tea I will
fight you in the US we have way more
cold drink options than hats here are
the following exclusive code drink
options first up cinnamon roll cold brew
iced coffee uh
another victim of the Uber driver
I'm falling apart pretty good
too sweet then we got the raspberry
lemonade also
missing two inches ubified
I mean I don't want to give the guy a
bad rating but like look I have not
sipped any of these
oh my God this res lemonade is great
shout out to Greta thorberg I'm going to
use the uh use my straw twice I care
about the environment
no more single-use plastic this is the
frozen raspberry lemonade
whoa that's like powerful
this is really good bottle of milk
no thanks and of course
Fountain drinks and in the most bummed
because out of all the drinks that
spilled
we have so many flavors to choose from
let's get those on the screen
but the one I specifically wanted was
this one was the pib extra
pip extra is perfectly fine it's a Dr
Pepper wannabe back in the 90s 97 98 or
whatever Mr Pibb changed its formula to
pib extra they're trying to get in a Dr
Pepper's market share it's so annoying
but the problem is is that there's no Mr
Pibb anymore
30 years
of no Mr pip is ridiculous I am using my
platform right now to talk to the
executives at pib extra or Mr Pibb
release the Mr pib recipe I'm begging
you it doesn't have any value for you
you're not making it so there's no value
right you're just sitting on the recipe
you're not even making it it's worthless
to you it's Priceless to me and I don't
want you people watching this happened
last time people were messaging me like
oh yeah we got Mr Pibb here at the
Walmart it's like it's been extra it's
not Mr Pibb they're different okay if
anyone watching has cans of Mr Pibb from
the 90s connect with me I will buy it
off of you I'll pay for the shipping
that stays in the video or I quit we
have a few exclusive cold drinks over
here in the UK including an ice latte a
strawberry lemonade and a mango lemonade
I got the strawberry lemonade today
pretty Pleasant quite refreshing also in
the UK is it true that you guys
considered lemonade to be more like a
carbonated lemon beverage like Sprite
that's true Joe if you ask for a
lemonade in the UK expect something
that's carbonated and usually clear so
more like a Sprite although I will say
Cinnabon seem to be doing it kind of the
American way so maybe it approved for
that one now you can also get something
called a chilata in the US and the UK
however over here they come in flavors
of Oreo cookies and cream strawberries
and cream which I got and the double
chocolate mocha
that's just okay
don't bother in the UK children's come
in five flavors cinnamon roll strawberry
mango caramel latte and chocolate mocha
I got the cinnamon roll one today
actually looks pretty good
it also looks even more impressive when
the whipped cream was kind of in a nice
swirl
it's just like a again quite sweet but
pretty like luxurious cinnamony
milkshake
[Music]
I've gone to you can always smell it
before you see it it's impossible to
separate the scent of Cinnabon from the
mall and vice versa it's like
a soundtrack to the memory but how it
smells so Cinnabon is like the smell
track to malls
does that make sense and that's by
Design Cinnabon purposely put their
locations away from food courts and
other food stalls so the Cinnabon odor
would waft and not interfere with any
other smells so if you're in the mall
you smell Cinnabon and only Cinnabon and
that's almost like
nose marketing I don't know how you
would describe it and it's really smart
right because when you smell it man you
smell it you're like there it is I gotta
have one so it's in about a meal a snack
a dessert I'm gonna go with snack
um I feel like one of those regular
Cinnabons I could just eat one of those
easily maybe one and a half I don't
really know my Cinnabon limit I just
kind of find out about these little guys
and I feel like I could easily not got
half this tray ah I don't think it
should be a meal because that could like
do some damage to your body as far as a
dessert
it seems weird to me to eat a full meal
and then get a Cinnabon like it just
kind of like exists on its own so yeah
it's weird to consider it a snack but
you're definitely not having it for
lunch and you're definitely not having
it after a meal so by default snack
in the UK a single Cinnabon classic roll
will cost you two pounds 99 Pence which
at the time of recording this was 3.65
in the U.S a single Cinnabon classic
roll look seven dollars and 19 cents
that makes this single U.S rule 97 more
expensive that is hilarious but does the
price change if you bulk buy a six pack
of classic rolls in the UK will cost you
10 pounds 49 which at the time of
recording was 12.80 so by spending three
and a half times the amount of money
you're getting six times the amount of
Cinnabon which is a pretty good deal in
the US a six pack of Cinnabon classic
rolls will cost you 24.99
so even when you are bulk buying it's 95
more expensive to buy in the US for that
same 500 percent increase in food we pay
247 more money it's not often on food
Wars that it's much cheaper in the UK
than it is in the US to buy fast food
how's that feel Joe well it's Cinnabon
and I will pay whatever it takes this
stuff is amazing they could double the
price I'm still eating it
the UK Cinnabon website doesn't give a
full nutritional breakdown including
things like the fat and the sugar
content of Cinnabon however when we got
this sinner pack
I noticed that they actually have a full
breakdown on the box here we're given
the information for 100 grams worth of
classic Cinnabon rolls you might
remember from earlier when we weighed
one roll we found out that it was pretty
much exactly 200 grams so doubling those
numbers gives us the stats for a full
role in the UK here's everything that's
in a classic Cinnabon roll in the UK
so that's almost 40 of your daily
recommended calories eighty percent of
your daily saturated fat and over 110 of
your daily sugar to put the calories
into context one of these rolls is like
eating three McDonald's hamburgers
here's everything in a classic cinnamon
roll in the US
you are reading that right 61 grams of
sugar and for some reason
1150 milligrams of sodium that puts us
slightly ahead of the UK in every single
category I mean look at that sodium that
is way higher for some reason that's
exactly 50 of your daily sodium in one
roll what about some other even more
unhealthy menu items the most calorific
role in the UK is the Lotus Biscoff roll
which clocks in at 1019 calories that's
a hefty increase on the standard roll as
well as being over half of your daily
caloric allowance or as we now used to
quantify things for McDonald's
hamburgers the least healthy rule in the
U.S is the caramel pecan bun which is
1090 calories this is also the most
calorific thing on the entire U.S menu
sort of a single caramel pecan Bond roll
is 1090 calories but according to
Cinnabon if you get them in a pack of
four or six the calories of each
individual roll increases to 1160
it is unclear why that is the case but
I'm going to go ahead and guess because
they dump way more frosting on it the
most colorific thing on the UK menu
actually isn't a row it's this a 16
ounce cinnamon roll chalata one of these
contains a whopping
1231 calories that means that one of
these large cinnamon roll chilatas
combined with one of our classic
cinnamon rolls in the UK would put you
pretty much exactly at your 2000 calorie
daily limit
[Music]
cinnamon does not disclose a full
ingredients list in the U.S only
allergens the website in the UK also
didn't contain ingredients information
but once again
the Box provided us with all of the
ingredients of a classic cinnamon roll
and it is a lot
but are there any ingredients which you
need to look out for the by myself is
pretty much fine despite the sheer
number of ingredients the things to
watch out for are actually found in the
frosting the frosting contains an
imitation vanilla extract which in turn
contains e1520 this is also known as
propylene glycol it's fairly common in
foods and in small doses is used as a
carrier for ingredients which aren't
soluble in water however it can be toxic
in large doses it's one of the main
ingredients in antifreeze as it lowers
the freezing point of water too much
pripling glycol could lead to internal
bleeding and kidney failure
the good news is that you're unlikely to
ever hit these levels from food just
don't go drinking antifreeze the lemon
extract in the frosting also contains
e102 sometimes known as yellow 5 or
tartrazine it's a somewhat controversial
yellow food dye it was parts of a panic
in the UK about food colorings causing
hyperactivity in children although
eventually it was showing that there was
limited evidence for this a 2015 study
also found that yellow number five can
damage your white blood cells which
makes you likely to develop tumors and
cancer
see us out dancing rats
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Little Caesars in the US and the
UK this is fruit Wars
Little Caesars in the U.S sells hot and
ready pizzas in one size 14 inches
closer to 13 and a half I'll let it
slide though in the UK Little Caesar's
Hot and Ready pizzas only come in one
size 12 inches that means that the
surface area of a UK Little Caesar's
Pizza is 113.1 square inches the surface
area of a U.S Little Caesars Pizza is
153.94 square inches that makes the
pizza 36 percent larger than the UK's
now we can't get crazy bread in the UK
and we ordered it from our Little
Caesars but unfortunately they forgot it
if they remember your crazy bread it
looks like you get four pieces with an
order according to the website too bad
for the UK but the us we did get our
crazy bread in an order of crazy bread
comes with eight sticks eight crazy
sticks it wouldn't of course be a order
of crazy bread without the crazy sauce
to add insult to injury they gave us
just the crazy sauce but without the
bread let's wear anyway to see how much
we get a side of crazy sauce in the UK
weighs 7 grams so 159 grams
whoa it's so crazy it's fine I wouldn't
call the sauce crazy misunderstood maybe
but it feels like the sauce kind of has
it under control this is a very mild
mannered well thought out well-measured
sauce another item available in both
countries is cheese bread I'll say on
the medium rare side of cooked 7.5
inches across and 5.5 inches wide I
would like to note that in the U.S our
cheese bread is called Italian cheese
bread ooh that's almost exactly nine
inches seven inches if you want to get a
small Peach at a Little Caesar's just
got the Italian cheese bread inside of
sauce some assembly required
here are all the Little Caesars menu
items in the UK that you won't find in
the US here is all of the Little Caesars
menu items you can get in the US that
you won't find in the UK before we talk
about some of the default Pizza options
we'll talk about some of the
customization options you get in the UK
that you guys can't change in the US for
example over here we can sub out the
tomato sauce base for barbecue sauce or
Peri-Peri sauce I think the Peri Peri
sauce is kind of a nod to the UK's
obsession with Peri Peri you guys know
how much we love our Nando's I think
Little Caesars are trying to get in on
that as well Nando's just dropped to
their knees in Tesco just like oh my God
no the Peri-Peri option doesn't stop
there because you can also add piri pre
seasoning to the crust of your pizza at
all seasons the U.S customizations for
the crust round which I guess is regular
but we also have thin crust stuffed
crust Detroit style deep dish and
stuffed crust deep dish for bake we also
do a well done uh cheese you can get
obviously regular cheese but no cheese
or light cheese sauce same thing light
normal extra no sauce now let's talk
about some of the pizza options in the
UK you won't find on the menu in the US
here we have the barbecue chicken pizza
if you stare at this thing for too long
you will be lured into a hypnotic trance
the barbecue sauce is very sweet and
kind of becomes the main thing that you
can taste if that's your thing do it not
really mine over this way we have the
spicy Peri Peri
the Peri-Peri is quite gentle just like
a little bit of heat maybe but to call
that like a spicy Peri-Peri I think
they've oversold the spicy and they've
also kind of oversold the Peri-Peri our
next Pizza is this one it's called the
cuatro what they've done is take a pizza
and divide it into fours and then top
those individually so you have two
slices of Margarita two slices of
pepperoni two slices chicken and
mushroom and two slices of peppers
tomatoes and sweet corn all right this
says SC pepperoni stuffed crust
pepperoni I mean this looks like pretty
generously pepperoni it's a bit more
neon colored than I'd like the crust of
course is stuffed with mozzarella cheese
yeah yeah not bad I also try
sorry stuff gross people just kind of
don't care about it something newer to
the Little Caesars menu here in the US
is something called slice and sticks
which is half Pizza half breadsticks for
the consumer that wants a little variety
just them by themselves don't want to
get a whole pizza and a whole thing of
sticks I want to point out that slicing
sticks come in what I think is this aka
the classic we also get bacon slice and
sticks and jalapeno slicing sticks throw
on your grass skirts ladies and
gentlemen we're going to Hawaii this is
the Hula Hawaiian which of course is
bacon and pineapple
I think pineapple and Peach is perfectly
fine this hawaiian's not very good but
the before mentioned thin crust thin
crust pepperoni it's pretty good if you
want to pay the exact same price for
literally half the pizza so far for
Little Caesars the pepperoni is winning
across the board Little Caesars got me
through some Financial rough patches
don't be too hard on them but I mean
some of them like oh yeah my early 20s
great five meat Feast count with me here
pepperoni ham sausage hamburger bacon
and yeah I think it's like a seasoned
beef I don't like when they go ham and
pork or two different Meats I know
they're two different but it's kind of
like they're pretty close or it should
be five meats two animals the seasoned
ground beef or sausage looks a lot like
Mouse turds making this incredibly
unappetizing
you're trying too hard with this one
then we have a few Deluxe options in the
UK starting with a pepperoni Deluxe if
you're wondering what makes this Deluxe
when compared to a standard pepperoni
they just take some extra pepperoni and
add it to the pizza and then sprinkle it
with granapadano cheese I will say like
it doesn't look slightly more deluxe
than the rest let's see if it tastes
Deluxe
it might just be a placebo effect but it
does kind of taste like the best one
I've had so far I don't know if I'd
stretch to like deluxe as an adjective
but slightly better for sure maybe just
rename it the slightly better pepperoni
something that here in the US Our Little
Caesars has I've never heard of this
before and I don't know exactly what
they're they're doing a series of pizzas
two pizzas called and this is all one
word extra most bestest the extra most
bestest cheese and pepperoni is this
just rebranding the plain cheese in the
plain what makes this extra most bestest
all right let's find out together it's
upgrade take under classic pepperoni
pizza that offers 80 percent more
pepperoni uses 25 more cheese okay so
more cheese and more pepperoni wait a
second wait a second wait a second
because someone Graphics take a
screenshot of that well we'll compare
this to there's there's a pepperoni
that's coming up that has a lot more on
here so next up is another Deluxe option
the margarita Deluxe just as like a
linguistic note in the UK if you see a
cheese and tomato pizza on the menu it's
almost always referred to as a margarita
everyone knows what that means it's a
slightly more traditional Italian way of
saying cheese and tomato whereas in
America it seems like you guys all just
have to say cheese pizza or you don't
really understand what you're getting to
turn this Margarita into a deluxe
version it seems like all they've really
done is added I think some herbs and
then some chopped up pieces of actual
tomato
all I really have to say about most of
these is that they're fine our final
Deluxe pizza exclusive is the mushroom
Deluxe again it looks like a fairly
standard mushroom pizza with I think the
herbs again and the granapadano
sprinkled around the edge it's also
funny that they call this one a mushroom
Deluxe pizza because there isn't
actually a standard Mushroom on the menu
so I guess if you uh like mushrooms on
your pizza you're being forced into
having the deluxe fancy version this
is the old world
fanceroni pepperoni go wrong now that's
pepperoni let's go the cups oh yeah now
remember when a minute ago that we just
saw that was the the extra best mostest
whatever the hell it's called yes yes
this is pretty good I will say the Dylan
all these pizzas are a lot spongier I'm
hoping that that is a choice to make it
spongier and not that they just didn't
cook these through I'll find out in a
couple hours of the regular round pizzas
last and certainly least veggie
as before mentioned version of pizza you
can get here in the US we have a Detroit
style deep dish pizza at Little Caesars
you can get the ultimate Supreme the
veggie the pepperoni the three meats
Hawaiian and just regular cheese I went
with the pepperoni because I feel that's
classic Detroit style hmm Detroit let us
know in the comments how they did true
Detroit style puts the sauce or a little
bit of sauce on top they did not so it
just looks like a really thick Pizza
love our bread in this country
I would suggest against selling this in
Detroit
so what we have here is the UK only
Pizza what we've done is take all of the
customization options you can only find
in the UK and combine them onto one
pizza so what this pizza has is the
Peri-Peri sauce base a barbecue sauce
drizzle Peri Peri chicken regular
chicken red onions sweet corn and
tomatoes
honestly that's not terrible far from
the worst UK only creation that we've
ever met the Perry sourced base seems to
just be tomato sauce with like a bit of
Perry seasoning kind of mixed into it so
you still get a bit of the sweetness
from the tomato and a very gentle warmth
from that the barbecue sauce is kind of
the dominant flavor again but as far as
UK only pizzas go it's not bad a segment
that usually we haven't done this in
forever it feels like a USA only that's
right this is a pizza you can only get
in the United States of America add a
little scissors of all the many USA only
options we went with a well done pizza
with a stuffed crust extra sauce light
cheese old world pepperoni pineapple and
black olives oh man
the extra sauce I think is what really
oh God the extra sauce is what really
ruined this because now it's just all
slide enough
it's really bad it's really bad because
it's like falling apart and also we got
this separately so this was actually
just came out of the oven it's like
really hot then we're on to the sides we
have two exclusives in the UK now while
we didn't get any of the crazy bread at
least we got the crazy Puffs they take
the dough they form it into a kind of
cupcake muffin shape which is then
filled with some tomato sauce some
cheese and pepperoni them to the grease
like dripping out of that as soon as I
bit him they're not bad they're on like
a mid level of the crazy scale and we
can also get veggie crazy puff it's the
same cheese and sauce base but then
instead of the pepperoni they've added
corn peppers and onion we also have
stuffed crazy bread remember that crazy
bread from earlier now it's stuffed
this is like a giant mozzarella stick
isn't really melted
oh man remarkably Bland avoid the
Caesar's got Wings oven roasted barbecue
and buffalo I'm starting to get a
headache I can't for life of me depend
on what is making me suddenly so
nauseous we have a couple of exclusive
sources in the UK which means it's time
for sauce talk we have three sources in
the UK that you won't find on an
American menu which is garlic and herb
when you order a Domino's it comes by
default with a garlic and herb dip in
the UK people go crazy for that dip
people really love it so a few other
places have tried to kind of jump on
that bandwagon and this is their version
we then have a Peri-Peri sauce and
finally we have a ketchup on the menu
I'm questioning anybody who eats pizza
with ketchup I'm gonna be honest and we
don't really even have any sides on the
menu that go with ketchup so the garlic
and herb is defeating me Leon help
thank you
it's got quite a harsh taste actually
surprisingly harsh try the Peri Peri
so the thing is piri piri has a very
distinct flavor it's a specific type of
chili all I'm really getting from this
is just like chili pepper heat we have
ketchup can't quite put my finger on it
I'm gonna literally put my finger on it
it's got almost more of like a tomato
soup flavor to it which I don't hate
after my Preamble about how much I do
not think ketchup should go with any of
these pizzas it actually ended up being
my favorite of these three sauces I
think that's more of a comment on the
other two not being very nice rather
than the ketchup being good you have a
variety of four exclusive delicious
dipping sauces butter garlic flavor
buffalo ranch cheesy jalapeno and just
regular Ranch it's the seasons in the UK
also has one dessert option you won't
find in the US chocolate chip cookies
so we got desserts cookie dough brownies
one is Twix pieces you know those m m
Minis
very very sweet kind of weird actually
finally let's talk about drinks in the
UK Little Caesars carries Coca-Cola
branded drinks including obviously
Coca-Cola but then also things like
Monster Energy and Oasis which is a bit
of a British classic comes another
Citrus Punch or summer fruits it's kind
of like a diluted fruit juice refreshing
fine I can have something to drink they
had Coke products we got Pepsi products
oh you know the classic Pepsi my group
here Mountain Dew and Starry it's the
new one it's what replaced Sierra Mist
R.I.P Sierra Mist thank God
and it's like exactly what seven up
tastes like they invented seven up great
job guys
unfortunately Little Caesars in the UK
doesn't give us a full nutritional
breakdown only calories a hot and ready
cheese pizza in the UK is 1 700 calories
that's 85 of your recommended daily
allowance a hot and ready U.S cheese
pizza is 1 950 calories that's 97.5 of
your recommended daily intake also the
sodium good Lord 160 of your recommended
daily intake the most calorific Pizza in
the UK is this three meat treat a whole
one of these contains 1910 calories or
95.5 of your daily allowance we also
have the three meat treat but ours is
2870 calories that's 960 calories more
than the UK version and ours is 143.5
percent of your daily calories you're
not going to believe this the three meat
treat isn't our biggest calorie pie that
award goes to oddly enough this the
pepperoni and cheese stuffed crust pizza
this whole thing 3 300 40 calories
that's 167 percent of your daily calorie
intake and of course the sodium the
sodium
380 your recommended daily sodium intake
so pizza's cut in eight slices so one
slice contains 1094 milligrams of sodium
which is almost half of your daily
amount in just one slice rip my kidneys
a hot and ready Margarita or pepperoni
in the UK will cost you five pounds
which at the time of recording this is
six dollars and four cents a Little
Caesar's hand ready pizza has become a
contentious Topic in the US in recent
years forever this was just five dollars
but in 2022 they raised the price for
the first time in nearly 25 years price
can vary depending on your location but
where I am here in Southern California a
hot ready cheese pizza is now 6.49 or 5
pounds 40. our most expensive pizzas are
the ultimate Supreme spicy Peri Peri
barbecue chicken and three meat treat
which will all cost you 10 pounds this
was my first time trying Little Caesar's
pizza because currently there is only
one of them in the whole UK it's in
chellaston just near Derby having now
tried it and also with the context of
the price I think I'm fairly confident
in saying this is a pretty low rung
Pizza it is very rare to find anything
of this size four or five pounds in the
UK when you come to pizzas but in kind
of return for that you're not getting
the best quality I think in terms of my
taste of pizza power rankings for the UK
this would be sitting fairly low but for
five pounds it's kind of hard to
complain because that is quite cheap I
don't know how do you feel about it Joe
when researching for this video I looked
it up and I was surprised to find out
and you might be surprised as well to
learn this Little Caesars is the third
biggest pizza chain in America totally
surprised Little Caesars recently became
the official pizza at the NFL what I
always thought this is me talking here
Little Caesars was always the cheapest
option also the quality was
never that good so I was surprised to
learn that this pizza is a still around
B very popular and see after this video
and not that bad I dogged in Little
Caesars for a while but I mean I've had
worse
when calorie counts of potion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Tim Hortons in the US and the UK
this is food pools
[Music]
coffees at the UK Tim Hortons come in
three portion sizes the small which is
12 ounces a regular which is 16 ounces
and a large which is 20 ounces so hot
coffee from a U.S Tim Hortons comes in
four sizes small 10 ounces medium 15
ounces large 20 ounces and extra large
24 ounces let's measure the largest
coffee in both countries to see if we're
getting as much as we've been promised
it's supposed to be 24 ounces it's 22
ounces so we're missing two ounces I
don't know where they went I personally
don't care if there's two ounces missing
but I feel like there are people who
would take this very seriously I assume
if you're getting an extra large you
want all 24 ounces they've actually only
given us 18 ounces two whole ounces
missing
doesn't stop that
like for when you need 12 cups of coffee
for yourself or I've seen friends but
probably yourself honestly
I don't drink coffee so if I drank this
whole thing I think I would die you know
people are like oh this is how you kill
a Victorian child like this is how you
would kill me I feel like this is what
Joe drinks like every morning
Tim Horton's signature iced caps also
come in three sizes in the UK and
they're supposed to be the same sizes as
our hot coffees 12 16 and 20 ounces when
we got these I was shocked I've never
seen one before and they kind of look
like slushies they've sort of melted a
little bit and gone a little bit sad our
ice caps only come in three sizes small
12 ounces medium 16 ounces and large 20
ounces so the same as the UK
okay actually really similar to colada
like very very similar again let's check
the biggest one to see if we're getting
as much as we've been promised
oh of the big lump oh no oh no oh no oh
it's just under 16 ounces
it's supposed to be 20 so we're missing
four ounces maybe they gave us four
ounces of whipped cream I don't know the
liquid line is only actually coming up
to like 13 fluid ounces there is another
line of like foamy stuff which takes you
closer to
17. I don't know how much you can count
the phone because I feel like that's not
proper liquid I don't know enough about
fluid dynamics to I don't know if that's
actually true or not but in my mind
we've been shortchanged here 13 ounces
of actual Liquid Plus maybe three or
four ounces of foam
it's actually really tasty this is like
dangerously good I don't want to stop
drinking this I've got a long shoot out
of us let's go they're already pretty
sweet but apparently you can get these
made with chocolate milk so you can get
it even sweeter it's their secret menu
item Donuts from a UK Tim Hortons come
in three portion sizes as a single donut
as a box of six
or as a dozen donuts these look really
good in the U.S we also get Tim Horton's
Donuts in serving sizes of one
six
and twelve the donuts themselves a
different size in the US or the UK we're
going to weigh a glazed old-fashioned
donut to find out
so close
68 grams god grow up Harry
whoa we're 58 grams so we're missing 10
grams it's like suspicious is your
flower heavier I feel like you've rigged
your scale I don't know I'm gonna put
out some conspiracy theories
Tim Horton's Timbits come in three sizes
in the UK
there's a box of ten
there's a box of 20
or a larger size
there's a box of 50. U.S 10 bits come in
four portion sizes
one
ten
twenty and 40. this is what is so funny
I don't think there's munchkins with
sprinkles on
Tim Hortons is kind of gourmet oh my God
it's so dense this is really good these
are not like munchkins I take that back
I'm so sorry Duncan Village I still love
you in the uh Dunkin Donuts episode I
tried to fit as many donut holes in my
mouth at once as I could
so you know what this means
stupid
do this every time
guy thing but yeah
[Music]
everybody
okay
all right stop now
nine
I thought I could foot ton in my mouth
they're really done so I think if they
weren't as done so I could put more
I don't wanna admit I don't want to
admit Harry One
this was rigged
um I don't know how but it was great it
was definitely red I don't know man yeah
okay Harry would
whatever we still won the Revolutionary
War
[Music]
here are the Tim Hortons menu items from
the UK that you won't find in the US
and here's everything at a U.S Tim
Hortons you won't find in the UK we'll
start down this end with the donuts this
is the Canadian maple donut this is the
maple caramel donut the rainbow donut
the strawberry and vanilla donut in
banoffee pie chocolate brownie donut a
caramel apple fritter and a red velvet
cheesecake donut these are almost like
too much for me a lot of these ones I
work a slightly more simple taste when
it comes to Donuts I like just a classic
Jam I think it's the chocolate brownie
one that's calling my name the most it's
not bad
the donut itself is slightly dry
as are the brownie chunks on top
so I think the two of those combine to
give back a fairly dry donut experience
maybe like a little more sauce in the
middle or just wash it down with a nice
cap and then you've been fine
we also have some exclusive Donuts not
as many but you know we have four this
is the Honey Dip
sour cream glazed this one does look
cool
chocolate dip which this does just look
like a chocolate donut so like
I don't really understand how this is
exclusive and this is the honey honey
crueler crawler I don't know how to
pronounce it no actually we're gonna
check that real quick
interesting and related word
crawler
crawler ladies straight forward once you
know
and now you know I'm probably not saying
it completely right but I think we're
going to live with it because I think we
try to say it completely right it's just
going to be worse for all of us the
honey honey Cruller
I like doing taste the honey at first
but it's good I didn't want to try the
sour cream one
I don't know if I like the sour cream
with the you taste the sour cream you
like taste and smell it right away I
think
goodbye
we also have a couple of exclusive
10-bit varieties sour cream glazed
Timbit and the sour cream blueberry
glazed to me they really like sour cream
huh or do they think we like sour cream
so they're adding it to everything it's
like when you go to like the American
aisle of like a grocery store in another
country and it's just all like
containers of sour cream we also have a
load of breakfast options that you won't
find in the US we'll start with this one
it's a veggie sausage and egg muffin I
gotta say this looks pretty good this is
a vegetarian sausage patty with cheese
and egg as you might imagine this looks
good like the texture looks there it's
kind of got those like fibers that
you're used to for me honestly that's
not bad at all there is a chance
that you could give this to me
and I would not know that it wasn't me
which for a meaty tour is pretty much
the highest praise that I can give them
next up we have an option called the
stack so for both the sausage and the
bacon muffins you have the option to
turn it into a stack what this means is
adding a hash brown into your muffin I
don't really understand where the stack
thing came from in the UK because Tim
Hortons aren't the only ones doing it I
think Subway also have like sub Stacks
where you can just add hash browns to
anything and apparently that makes it a
stack in the US we have avocado toast
options I was gonna hold it up like the
Animal Crossing so it's kind of flimsy
when they hold up like the fish and
they're like this is what I caught
the bread's just really thin I feel like
avocado Hills usually comes with like a
really like crusty piece of bread like
really thick and we're on to breakfast
sandwiches both in the form of English
muffins and bagels there's the double
stacked breakfast sandwich which we
weren't able to get we have the sausage
Bagel breakfast sandwich
bacon Bagel breakfast sandwich the egg
and cheese bagel breakfast sandwich and
the bagel b-e-l-t
acon egg lettuce and tomato that's
interesting I ever heard of that before
it doesn't it doesn't look like a bad
Bagel but this isn't the bagel I would
want to go and get it doesn't feel right
yeah it does feel I don't know if it
feels rubbery but it's like actually the
inside's a little
I don't know about that yeah we're
filming this in New York we have high
standards for bagels the UK has one
breakfast wrap option the big breakfast
wrap which contains a hash brown egg
bacon cheese and sausage that looks like
the equivalent of our
loaded Farmer's breakfast wrap
we got it out this is happy I wonder why
they call ours the loaded Farmer's
breakfast but there's like the big
breakfast so that they think like this
is what like American farmers eat and
they're like oh that's a big breakfast
like that's what I want today I don't I
don't think this is what would keep me
going
if I needed to go out on the farm for a
day but we can also get the loaded
breakfast wrap and then the breakfast
wrap snacker this is little and cute
it's a snack wrap dupe sorry McDonald's
bring it back
you know snack size that's the right
size next up the UK has Bagels on the
menu you can get these either as plain
or with cream cheese I think I did ask
for cream cheese and they might have
forgotten it and now I just have a very
dry Bagel which I will probably not be
eating over here we love our bagels and
Tim Hortons reflects that by providing
lots of options we have the everything
bagel
cinnamon raisin bagel the 12 grain bagel
and a pretzel bagel I don't know if I've
seen before it's a it's a cool flavor in
theory and I appreciate the options I
think it's cool that they're trying to
provide a good variety for us they have
more Bagel options than I thought they
would have if Bagels aren't for you but
you want another kind of bread thing we
also have toast on the menu of the UK
although they wouldn't actually give it
to me today because they've run out of
the jam that it's usually served with so
unfortunately I couldn't get it the next
one is a classic British breakfast item
the bacon roll as the name suggests it's
a bread roll with bacon you can get them
with a range of sauces this one has
ketchup I think you can also get brown
sauce compared to the standard fast food
bacon quality that I'm used to seeing
this is like a pretty pretty thick piece
of like back British bacon compared to
like McDonald's bacon this has way more
flavor actually taste of pork which is
always nice we can also get breakfast
biscuit options we have the simply
sausage biscuit and then we have the
simply bacon biscuit I know this is
controversial biscuits and scones aren't
the same thing I'm sorry the scones are
definitely denser I get that they might
look similar so maybe putting biscuits
with Savory things seems weird but it's
it's not I think you just need to try
like a good Southern biscuit I say as a
girl from New Jersey because I clearly
know what I'm talking about but this
isn't a scone they're not similar at all
I'm annoying because I've gone to
afternoon tea here in the US and in
London so I know the difference it's not
the same thing UK's importance also
sells pancakes now these are American
style pancakes so they are small round
and thicker than British pancakes which
tend to be more like crepes
they come in portions of two this one
comes with
some Nutella you can also get maple
syrup pancakes which is just the same
but with a little thing of maple syrup
or maple flavored golden syrup because
apparently that's what we have in the UK
or you can get bacon maple pancakes
which are two pancakes with bacon and
also the syrup although
the bacon pancakes
um other is more okay there's more I I
thought that
I thought that this was the only bacon
that we had on our maple bacon pancakes
but thankfully they've actually layered
it
with some more underneath the bacon that
you're getting on the pancakes isn't the
same bacon as you're getting in your
bacon roll this is like streaky bacon
that's what we call it in the UK whereas
this is what we would call back bacon
which has the kind of like Medallion and
then the little fatty bit on the end not
sure why they haven't just used
one uniform type of bacon for the whole
menu so British people bacon and
pancakes is like kind of a weird
combination as it is so I don't think it
would have been made significantly
weirder by putting like British bacon on
these we go to a store and get Canadian
bacon which is ham which is I guess this
British bacon it's like well they call
it back bacon like this is getting
overly complicated there's bacon and
then there's ham that is ham our last
breakfast items are these omelette bites
which come in spinach and egg whites and
bacon and cheese these are basically
like Starbucks's egg bites which are
good I love them but
I feel like the spinach chunks are kind
of big I don't know and then we have the
croissant which I don't I don't know if
they all look like this but it's kind of
making me uncomfortable at the ends are
touching I feel like they shouldn't do
that I don't know it's like when you
walk in on your toothbrushes touching
you know then we have some sort of
breakfast sort of snack exclusives
the chocolate chip muffin the fruit
explosion muffin I don't know what
fruits are going to be exploding it'd be
cool if it was like a gusher situation
if you're gonna put explosion in the
name I feel like you should be doing
something and the wild blueberry muffin
we also get two cookies you can't get in
the UK chocolate chunk cookie and
oatmeal raisin cookie which I still
don't know who would willingly eat an
oatmeal raisin cookie do you eat oatmeal
raisin
oh both of you
well yeah that's like no one actually
likes oatmeal raisin cookies is when
someone when someone brings in oatmeal
raisin cookies you're hoping it's
chocolate chip and when you find out
it's oatmeal raisin you're like what the
I just don't go why you would want
raisins in a cookie I'm sorry
now later in the day you can get lunch
options from a UK Tim Hortons
unfortunately we went there slightly too
early to actually get these but if you
arrive later here are the exclusive
options Tim's crispy chicken stuck with
or without bacon Tim's crispy chicken
sandwich crispy meatless chicken
sandwich grilled chicken wrap or Crispy
Chicken Wrap a tuna wrap or a vegan wrap
chicken tenders
chicken and mozzarella Panini tuna and
cheese melt ham and cheese melt tomato
and basil soup or potato wedges the
lunch options exclusive to the US
include a tuna salad sandwich chicken
salad sandwich turkey bacon club ham and
swiss sandwich BLT chipotle steak wrap
chipotle chicken bacon wrap chipotle
chicken wrap and chili
because you know that's that's what we
really want I guess I do like chili but
that's interesting now let's look at
some drinks you can only find at the UK
Tim Hortons because I've only looked at
the US menu so I'm going to say it you
can only find in the UK I bet some of
these will be available in Canada and
there's going to be angry Canadians in
the comments how angry Canadians really
get I feel like they're pretty polite in
general let's start with some cold
beverages over here we have an iced cap
Supreme so a supreme basically means
that they've added some extra whipped
cream and then some topping pieces to an
iced cup you can get these in a couple
of flavor and Topping options there was
one that was coconut for example this
one is Oreo so you get the extra whipped
cream with some little crushed Oreo
pieces the standard ice cap was already
really sweet so I'm not sure it needs
Oreo but okay we can also get milkshakes
at a Tim Hortons in the UK these come
with a range of options including
vanilla strawberry chocolate Maple or a
dairy-free mango and coconut
foreign
took me a minute but hey uh banoffee
Shake as well then we have some hot
drink options as well here we have a
caramel macchiato you can of course get
an English breakfast tea we're in the UK
you can't really open a place and not
put this on the menu
we're continuing the banoffee menu item
theme with a banoffee latte which I'm
less convinced by
yeah banana coffee isn't really one that
I have tried before
I guess technically you could have
banoffee to mean banana coffee but I
think uh if you've got banana and toffee
right there just stick with the classic
we can also get a flat white in the UK
we can also get a chai latte and a red
velvet hot chocolate sandwich van with
match of the day music
here are U.S exclusive cold drinks
cinnamon sugar oatmeal cold brew vanilla
flavored cream cold brew with chocolate
cold foam caramel cream cold brew with
cold foam mocha cream cold brew of cold
film sunrise sunset Tim's boost with Red
Bull sky's the limit Tim's boost with
Red Bull orange Tangerine Refresher
fruit smoothie mixed berry and frozen
lemonade
here are the U.S exclusive hot drinks
the take 12 which coffee is not
exclusive but you can only get this
giant size in the U.S French vanilla and
steep tea and that's interesting that
the UK doesn't get steep tea because you
know
UK apparently this is really popular in
Canada and it's it's just tea that's
made by instead of Brewing you like
leave the leaves in in either cold or
hot water and eventually the flavor
comes through but my friend said that
this is really really popular and they
have different flavors so I'm gonna make
a double double to apparently a big
thing in Canada for Tim Hortons and it's
literally just coffee with two creams
Two Sugars but it's it's like a thing
unless I'm being set up by my friend
April don't do this to me
it's half and half the same thing as
cream or something right I used to drink
half and half like when I was a kid I
feel like some people think that's gross
but tastes like really good and I was
literally we'll go to Denny's and it's
like on the table and you're just like
let's go Two Sugars
a few times I do drink coffee you should
put like six to eight packets if that
but I like lined them up at once and rip
them so no one can tell how much sugar
I'm putting in so they can't judge me
maybe it tastes better when they make it
for you
it just tastes like coffee and I don't
like coffee that much so maybe that's
why can I have my diet coke down
a large iced cat from a UK Tim Hortons
costs four pounds 39 which is 5.30
us a large iced cap is 4.89 or 4.01
British pounds that makes a U.S large
ice cap 7.7 percent cheaper in the US
than the UK six donuts in the UK's
importance costs 80.99 which is 10.85 in
the U.S six donuts cost 8.99 or 7.38
British pounds 20 Timbits from the UK
Tim Hortons cost seven pounds 49 which
is around nine dollars and four cents in
the U.S 2010 bets cost 6.29 or 5 pounds
16. overall it honestly seems like
pretty good value compared to some of
the other fast food chains that are
comparable I suppose I feel like the
breakfast deal particularly was quite
good they had like a three pounds 49-ish
deal for a breakfast meal including the
muffin a hash brown and a drink which is
really good probably even better value
than McDonald's for example I really
love donuts I kind of wish Donuts were
more like commonplace in the UK because
they're not that big a thing I feel like
from what I've seen from Tim Hortons
today they've got what it takes they
should be pushing really hard into the
UK Market I do think that's demand for
this
[Music]
a large ice cap from the UK's importance
contains the following 399 calories 23
grams of total fat of which 15 grams are
saturated and 44 grams of carbs of which
42 grams are sugars that's 20 of your
daily calories 75 of your daily
saturates and 84 of your daily sugar
which is alarming because it's really
good
a large ice cap in the U.S contains the
following 393 calories
23.4 grams total fat 12.5 grams of
saturated fat
42.7 grams of carbs 38.2 of which are
sugars that means that apart from Total
fat content the U.S ice cap is actually
healthier than the UK's in every other
metric
although it's still 62.5 percent of your
daily saturated fat and 76.4 of your
daily sugar
you win some you lose some
milk.fandom.com
you're a huge fan of milk
it's the place to go oh there you go
there's a table thank you uh milk the
milk Wiki is educational this is a good
opportunity to explain the differences
between the standard dairy products used
in beverages in the US and the UK to me
this is an alarming amount of saturated
fat because usually when you're making a
beverage like this in the UK you'll be
using either semi-skimmed milk or maybe
whole milk in the UK semi-skimmed milk
contains somewhere between one to two
percent fat content and then we have
whole milk which contains closer to 3.5
to 4 percent of that these are pretty
comparable to the American equivalent so
you guys have so many skim milk but
that's I think 1.5 to 1.8 fat and then
you have whole milk which is around 3.25
what's interesting about Tim Hortons in
the UK is that they've adopted a
slightly more American approach to their
beverages so what they've done is
actually made this with single cream
instead of with milk the fat content of
single cream in the UK is around 18
which I think is around what half and
half is in the US but here that is very
much the exception rather than the norm
this is very rare you will not see this
in many places if you're making your
beverages with coffee cream in the U.S
that can even range from 18 to 30 some
of that content that's crazy honestly
it's tasty but I would not want to drink
these every day because that is not good
for you the most calorific Timbit in the
UK is the white chocolate birthday cake
Timbit coming in at 94 calories per bit
one of these also contains 8.5 grams of
sugar which means that just one of those
and a large ice cap contains your entire
daily sugar allowance also means that I
was able to fit almost a thousand
calories in my mouth at once who knew
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Denny's in the US and the UK
this is food Wars
this is an All-American slam breakfast
at a UK Denny's it consists of two
scrambled eggs with cheddar two sausages
two pieces of bacon some American style
hash brown and two triangles of toast
this bacon looks a little sad I know you
guys like crispy bacon in the US an
All-American slam breakfast in the US
comes with the following by default
three scrambled eggs with cheese two
bacon strips two sausage links hash
browns and a choice of either four
triangles of toast or two pancakes we
went with pancakes the largest breakfast
in the UK is this the Grand Slam Slugger
it's the same as the All-American slam
but instead of the toast you get two
pancakes now when I saw this on the menu
I didn't think changing the toast for
pancakes would actually add that much
size to it but these things are huge I
think two of these plus the rest and
that is a substantial breakfast
our largest slam is The Lumberjack slam
it comes with two pancakes two or three
eggs I can't tell grilled ham you have a
choice of two satches links and two
bacon strips or four of either so I went
with four bacon strips hash browns and
four triangles of toast look at this now
here is a guy who's ready for a full day
of lumber jacking
you can get some of Denny's iconic
sandwiches in the UK including
the grand slamwich we're gonna wear a
grand slamwich in both countries to see
whose is bigger
[Music]
now we all know the moons of
late version I didn't know this but
apparently now is in Sandwich version
here it is you can add the eggs you got
the ham right this is a UK Moon's over
my hammy I don't get that pun I'm really
sorry guys
no Diner be complete without American
style pancakes in the United States an
order of Pancakes comes by default as a
two-piece
one two one two an order of Pancakes in
the UK also means two pancakes however
when I went to order them on the website
it also gave me the option to add a
single additional extra pancake for 199
and it let me do that up to 99 times so
if you do really really love pancakes
you can order 101 pancakes from your UK
Denny's for a small small price of 203
pounds and 80 Pence but how big are the
pancakes themselves we're going to
measure them to find out so our pancake
I'm gonna say 16 centimeters across and
the pancake weighs
around 147 grams six inches
I once caught a pancake this big yeah
again the Tinder profile like
the weight of a sink of the same pancake
this specific six inch pancake at
Denny's weighs
148 grams
here are all the items you'll find at a
UK Denny's that you won't find in the US
and here's everything you'll find at a
US Denny's you will not find in the UK
let's start with the breakfast items uh
largest slam breakfast the Grand Slam
Slugger is in fact an exclusive we have
a couple exclusive slam breakfasts in
the US the before mentioned Lumberjack I
mean I'm curious about this this ham
it's fried ham steak if you want to eat
something
at Denny's that doesn't go straight for
your arteries you can get the fit slam
it is two English muffins I see a
spinach egg whites Tomatoes looks like
Feta cheese let's get in here I bet
that's great when it's hot but it is not
hot and therefore it is not great next
up we have the veggie breakfast in here
we have what seems to be like an
omelette made with kind of peppers some
spinach and maybe some onion as well
there are these little cubes
performance cubes little square things
of potato
and then just a couple of bits of either
boiled or steamed broccoli and if you're
not eating eggs we have a vegan version
it looks like all they've really done is
just replace the eggs with more potato
Benny which is of course short for eggs
Benedict everything needs a fun name in
America
with a poached egg ham
Hollandaise sauce not to be confused
with holiday sauce
of course we also have a Southwest
bending Southwest oh wait no there's a
as a chorizo and stuff that actually
kind of rules I'm surprised that's
actually pretty good something that may
mystify the UK viewers as you will see
various versions throughout this video
of what I'm about to show you biscuits
and gravy chicken biscuits and gravy
it's gonna be some sort of combination
of fried chicken or some cases steak
smothered in the white gravy we have a
gravy that is filled with sausage and
also on our biscuits deep fried chicken
covered in our white sauce it's gravy
that's sausage flavored cheese not a
scone
damn it that's really good next to that
is a Santa Fe well again the Santa Fe
just mean like salsa and chorizo get
these type of potatoes these sliced up
seasoned ones plus some mushrooms and
veggies another fried gravy thing this
is a country fried steak yes a steak
that has been fried and put are white
gravy on it and it also comes with eggs
McNugget that's kind of more beef
flavored and speaking of steaks you get
a T-bone steak and eggs
Denny's
what's with the onions and mushrooms
guys I want a steak like I assure you
there was a steak underneath this yeah
there it is there it is T-Bone door stop
of a steak look at the size of this
thing I mean this is
man they they destroyed this piece of
meat this thing is like the most well
done thing I've ever been in here it's
like biting into a wallet skip the steak
at Denny's
we have a few omelette options in the UK
but only one of them is exclusive it's
the ham and cheese omelette I'm
surprised you guys don't have these in
America because I'd say ham and cheese
is probably the most commonly eaten
omelette in the UK so we have exclusive
omelets of our own and they are way more
elaborate than the UK's simple ham and
cheese here we have the mile high Denver
omelets the Ultimate Omelet and the
Philly cheesesteak omelet now you're
watching right now are thinking Hey Joe
which is which I have no idea so another
game we're going to play in this episode
is
omelette roulette
what's in the omelets what's in The
Omelette so I'm gonna take a bite of
each one and see if I can guess which
omelette it is all right
Denver
ham peppers onions cheese the next
omelet
I'm seeing sausage
the question is does the viewer wanted
to be tilted
if we could put a poll on the screen do
I Judy tilt it I think a lot of people
like please don't
yeah this is the ultimate one sausage
obviously bacon peppers onions mushrooms
tomato cheese
everything looks so wet
um just dripping with water and this one
must be there for the Philly cheesesteak
grilled prime rib peppers onions
mushrooms swiss cheese ooh Prime you
will not find the following pancake
options in the UK starting down here
they got the choco NaNa which is
chocolates and banana every one of these
comes with like eggs and yeah you just
don't get pancakes I feel like I want to
point this out are you aware UK 17
Harry's footage every pancake order
comes with eggs and hash browns and
meats look at this it's ridiculous
there's so much food next to that is the
double Berry I mean this is strawberries
oh
because it's a berry pancake yeah
actually it's not very good the
strawberries are weird hearty nine grain
pancakes uh I can't tell how many grains
are in this pancake can you
have no idea and the cinnamon roll
pancakes I'm sure at this point the
Cinnabon episode is out oh my God
oh that's trouble that's really good and
at the end this is really funny it's a
crepe a berry vanilla crepe there's
something weird with their strawberries
we have some exclusive pancake options
of our own one thing to point out is
that Americans have this kind of like
pancakes for breakfast culture and that
really does not exist in the UK over
here pancake generally means crepe so
like a thin pancake and they're
traditionally more eaten for dessert
Denny's pancakes in the UK are the kind
of thick American style ones however the
toppings and these sauces tend to
reflect our dessert pancake culture a
bit more we'll start with a classic
pancake topping which is Nutella I
pronounce it Nutella some people say
Nutella
I've definitely do Americans say Nutella
USA Nutella that's horrible please don't
do that it's Nutella over here we have
the double chocolate pancakes I think
the double chocolate refers to the
chocolate chips in the pancakes
themselves and also this rather large
amount of chocolate drizzle on top next
up we have some strawberry dream
pancakes
which have not held up super well in
transit I'll be honest these are looking
less like strawberry dream pancakes and
more like strawberry nightmare pancakes
sauce that's just like fallen off the
pancake
like a very sweet maybe like white
chocolate vanillary type cream thing
over here we have the Oreo cookie
pancakes I think there are chocolate
pieces or maybe the cookie pieces in the
pancake as well
then it's topped with some more of this
kind of sweet cream stuff they have next
up we have a Kinder Bueno pancake do
Americans know what kind of Bueno is
it's a chocolate bar very popular in
Europe and the UK I don't know what the
cream stuff inside of it is but
one of the best tasting things in the
world and then finally because it's near
Valentine's Day here in the UK while
we're filming this we can get some
Valentine's pancakes these red velvet
ones
these are the exact colors that you see
on snakes that you're supposed to run
away from if you see them in the wild we
don't have any Crepes on the menu in the
UK but we do have waffles these are also
generally desserts in the UK and Danny
serves them in the following flavors
here we have a fresh fruit waffle each
one seems to be one whole circular
waffle cut into quarters and then topped
with powdered sugar and some other
toppings with the fresh fruit one you're
getting some banana and some strawberry
here we have a golden waffle that's a
waffle with golden syrup which is kind
of like a British version of maple syrup
some of the waffles on the menu also
come as a liege style waffles liaise is
a place in Belgium Belgian waffles
they're a little bit more dense than the
American waffles next up we have a
Nutella waffle not Nutella then we have
a Kinder Bueno waffle the soy stuff
really does capture the flavor of Kinder
Bueno you can't just get a plain waffle
with just some of the whipped butter
that you get with the pancakes and then
finally another liaise option is the
banana and salted caramel waffle great
flavor combination big fan of that now
that we've reset the table let's move on
to some other options starting with
sandwiches start here with the New York
melt we're more American than the
Americans let's try the pastrami
we're not very good at like deli meats
in the UK on average
up next we have the three cheese melt
pretty much just a grilled cheese with
three types of cheese in here here we
have the Mac and Me This is a grilled
cheese sandwich filled with mac and
cheese and bacon bits we've just been
discussing double carbs
and establish that there are
circumstances where double carb is okay
but the bread pasta combination in this
circumstance seems to just unsettle me
for some reason I can't really put a
word to then our last exclusive sandwich
is the club sandwich you guys do have a
club sandwich in the US but I believe it
has avocado whereas ours does not we
have a bunch of exclusive sandwich
options in the US I mean the website
splits them into classic breakfast
options and meats and handheld options
all right we'll start with the breakfast
one the my hammy spice it's the same
thing except it's got Jalapenos in it
look at that this this thing is just
dripping with butter
and then we have the rest which I don't
think is supposed to be in for breakfast
they do have a brisket BQ melt and a
brisket all melt which is not able to
get today but what we do have is the
Cali club sandwich we also got the
Superbird
unless it's like turkey bacon and tomato
and juice
the Big Dipper melts this is just a what
looks of a patty melt with
about half a gallon of aju
look at that I love a good Paramount
that's a problem next up is this
monstrosity the fried cheese melt now
when I heard that and put in for the
order I was assuming it was gonna be
like kind of go waste like grilled
cheese like they fried cheese or just
it's just a funny way of saying grilled
cheese no no no
there's actually a sandwich that
consists of mozzarella sticks look at
this are you kidding me look at this I'm
gonna I'm gonna take the top of one of
these
and it even comes with marinara sauce
yeah it even says in the script that
Harry wrote mozzarella sticks sandwich
you've got to be kidding me we are not
kidding you apparently we have one
that's the stupidest thing I've ever
eaten other sandwiches you can get that
I did not get include the Nashville Hot
Chicken melts the BLT and the crispy
chicken bacon ranch
in one of the boxes when we were
unpacking everything I just found three
chicken tenders I was a bit confused
because we didn't order any chicken
tenders I ate them because I was hungry
and now looking back I realized that
that was part of one of our main options
which is chicken and waffles you get a
portion of plain waffles and three
chicken tenders and some maple syrup
combine them all Chicken and Waffles but
unfortunately
I've already gone sorry guys moving on
we have the barbecue bacon burger it's a
single cheeseburger with two large
rashes of bacon for the vegetarians UK
Denny's also has a veggie burger veggie
burgers just always look a bit sad don't
they also where's the sauce guys come on
this is dry as a bone it smells almost
like Falafel or maybe like a vegetable
Samosa and our last sandwich option is a
chicken burger
General note here Denny's uh please
Source your Burgers these are all quite
dry but here we have two chicken tenders
with a slice of cheddar cheese in a bun
this looks like a spaceship is there a
Star Wars spaceship that's shaped like
this that shape really like
I don't know I don't know what it is
then for the health conscious among us
we have two salad options starting with
the crispy chicken salad
and a grilled chicken salad in the US we
also have a ton of main course options
you won't find in the UK didn't get all
of them I will start with the burgers in
the U.S we have bacon Avocado Burger
there's also the before
shown slam Burger that's all the Grand
Slam breakfast in Burger form so weird
yet it exists let's get a little egg
hanging out here
and the Flamin five pepper Burger
there's also a bourbon bacon burger that
was not available at the time of filming
we also have bowls bowls bowls so many
bowls to choose from I only got one
that's the Mama D's pot roast I'm
assuming the d stands for Denny's or
delicious or deadly there's also the
crazy spicy bowl and the bourbon chicken
bowl entrees you saw a lot of this in
the breakfast section it's not to waste
much time on it first thing we got here
is the plate licking fried chicken and
this one I got a side of mashed potatoes
and a little veggie medley the next
thing we got here is the sirloin steak
who told you to smother this in onions
and uh mushrooms
another hockey puck other side you can
get fries and a veggie medley table
sticky stand up with corn and vegetables
that's right here
country fried steak dinner two country
fried steaks smothered in white sausage
gravy and of course comes with corn and
I think that's mashed potatoes and you
can also get a wild Alaskan salmon I'm
not bringing cooked fish in the studio
not happening all right use your
imagination and uh you can also get a
Cobb salad didn't get that either
because it's a salad what about the
exclusive starters and sides well in the
UK it's kind of like a beige Buffet here
we have chicken poppers just bite side
pieces of fried chicken
food is so dry I'm having to skip ahead
to the exclusives which thankfully for
me
includes beer
three of our UK exclusive sides are
actually forms of fries here we have
cheesy fries chips and cheese is a
classic British dish
so I'm glad that they have localized
their menu to the UK then in addition to
the cheesy fries you can add bacon to
create cheesy bacon fries and on top of
that you can add jalapenos
to create loaded fries this is like a
Pokemon evolving in its three stages
cheese fries evolves into bacon cheesy
fries
evolves into loaded fries
the Charizard of fries
then our last side dish is a British
classic
it's everyone's favorite
baked beans there they are these do
smell like British baked beans so kind
of like tomato based rather than
barbecue
I don't have a spoon should I just sip
from this like a little shot glass
no beans
what wouldn't this go with on the menu
is my question
uh I reckon a bean pancake could work
the attempted fate here
that's bad I can't even pretend that's
good Danny says boneless wings this is
what they look like
I don't know what sauce is they have for
dipping nobody asked other exclusive
sizing in the U.S you saw all the ones
from earlier these are ones that you've
probably seen before biscuits and gravy
scones and gravy and English muffin
ironically not in England that's weird
we also have right here this whole grain
rice
other sides that we have either mixed
within dishes you've seen or Not Seen It
All wavy cut french fries season cut
french fries red rustic mashed potatoes
I saw those somewhere the fresh
vegetable medley and the soup of the day
which is what I remember beef vegetable
and they told us couldn't get it till
after 11 and we picked up the food at 10
45. now run through the desserts
starting at the back here with chocolate
fudge cake with what at one point was
whipped cream then we have a few
cheesecake options starting with a
Reese's cheesecake doesn't look very
appealing they've just kind of dumps
what I assume is this kind of like
peanut buttery caramelly stuff on top of
it
it's not bad moving on from Reese's we
have an Oreo cheesecake it's the same
cheesecake but with Oreo pieces crumbled
on top finally a Nutella cheesecake has
fallen on its side so therefore I can
prop it up
like a TV then we have some french toast
options I'm not sure why Dennis
classifies these as desserts but
apparently chocolatey pancakes are a
breakfast food we'll start back here
with Oreo French Toast French toast not
much of a thing here in the UK what we
have is eggy bread which is like you
know the similar start where you take
the bread dunk it in egg and fry it but
then we'll kind of have it as a Savory
dish rather than as a breakfast slash
dessert then we have a banoffee French
toast the uninitiated banoffee is banana
and toffee Amalgamated together then we
have strawberry dream French toast fresh
strawberries and some vanilla ice cream
here's three exclusives you like in the
US and not the UK New York style
cheesecake whoa hey I'm walking here
the lava cookie Skillet I'm assuming
there's this I can't break it
and it comes with ice cream sure for
like dipping yeah pretty good
and the double chocolate pancake puppies
like hush puppies but pancake
then we have a couple more dessert
options and some milkshakes here we have
a strawberry ice cream sundae and a
caramel ice cream sundae ignore the
straw I definitely did not think it was
a milkshake I think we have identified
all the shakes uh I believe this is
millionaire shortbread peanut butter
shake a white chocolate and strawberry
shake cookie shake a vegan vanilla shake
then this I think is Bueno and this is
Nutella I think my favorite would
probably be the millionaire shortbread
one it's very sweet but very tasty and
after all that the final exclusive
alcohol thank God
we can get a few beer and other alcohol
options here in the UK including this
course light I think there's a Peroni
beer and some copperberg fruity cider
cheers guys
according to denny's.com a website I now
have an account with the nearest Denny's
to this studio in Burbank California and
All American slam will run you
15.29 an All-American slam from a UK
Denny's cost 10 pounds 99 which at the
time of recording this was 13.23 that
makes the American version 15 more
expensive than the UK's but there's
better value to be found Elsewhere on
the US menu a stack of pancakes
these very pancakes I'll just write two
of these cost 3.49 bro that is cheap two
pancakes in the UK that'll cost you five
pounds 79 which is around 6.97 that
means that the UK pancakes are 99 more
expensive I don't consider Denny's fast
food I consider more of a restaurant
chain like TGI Fridays even though
Denny's does really lean into breakfast
it is 24 hours so Denny's for me was
always a place that you can go at any
time just pretty much anything you would
find in a Diner you'll find at a Denny's
I used to go there a lot in high school
because you could smoke in a Denny's you
know someone 24 hours so we just drink
coffee smoke cigarettes split an
appetizer and drive our waitress crazy
Harry wants to know what time of day are
you going to a Denny's I think it's more
like what time of your life are you
going to Denny's to me I could be wrong
but the only people I see at Denny's are
teenagers who want to get out of the
house and hang out and they can't get
into a bar yet and retired people who
want to have a four dollar breakfast
so once you've come into this world on
your own
you start by going to Denny's with your
friends and you go off you live a life
you have a family a career you make an
impact in the world and once you retire
back to the same Denny's
full circle I like the stand-alone Diner
from the 50s has some name like berthas
or ethels or Fred's
add
you have as much coffee as you want
right get a Patty melts fries yeah that
to me just the chain is like no I like
this I like the Standalone place for me
I have to say this is quite expensive
for what it is we don't really have a
diner culture in the UK but what we do
have is calves calfs or short for Cafe
it's kind of like a ubiquitous British
thing you'll find a couple of caps in
every town where you can just get a
really cheap and cheerful meal on the go
in a hurry and it'll really really sort
you out generally for a lot less money
than what this will run you between caps
and greasy spoons which are similar but
not quite the same we really have kind
of breakfast culture covered in that
regard that's where you're going to get
your full English your toast your kind
of terrible cup of tea but in like quite
a nice way uh yeah so I'm not sure
Denny's would really be bringing too
much to the table when I say we don't
really have much of a dynaculture in the
UK I guess that's evidenced by the fact
that chains like Denny's really haven't
taken off over here we had to actually
travel to Wales to Swansea to get this
one because that's where our only
Denny's in the whole UK is I gotta say
it was kinda popular when we were there
it was pretty busy lots of families
taking their kids out for some food I
think maybe Denny's currently is just
more of a gimmicky American style thing
in the UK if they did try to roll out
I'm not sure that it would be really
kind of filling a void that we have that
isn't already filled by calves greasy
spoons or something else
unfortunately Denny's in the UK doesn't
disclose any of its nutritional
information Denny's in the US does
however so let's take a look at some
menu Classics one thing to note
especially with the slams is that
customizing your order can drastically
change the calories for example take
this All-American slam if you choose
turkey bacon as you meat hash brown is
your potato and white toast as your
bread it comes out to 1050 calories
respectable
on the flip side you get the
All-American slam with sausage links
french fries french fries come on and
then upgrade your toaster order of
cinnamon roll pancakes that doubles the
calories of the meal taking it to 2 300.
it's 115 of your daily recommended
intake and the main culprit here if it
wasn't obvious the cinnamon roll
pancakes just two of these contain 1 100
calories a nutritional information
document from Denny's did it back in
2020 also suggested that two cinnamon
roll pancakes with cream cheese icing
contains 157 grams of sugar that's 254
of your daily allowance zoom in for
effect
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between KitKat in the US and the UK this
is food Wars
in the US our kitkats come in nine sizes
yes really down here we got the smallest
The Minis unwrapped and we go up to the
fins after that Miniatures uh right here
we got the snack size and then the
classic standard four finger kitkats and
the big cats
the big cat king size the king size
and the
XL in the UK classic KitKat comes in
three sizes as these adorable little
bites as a two finger kit cut or as a
four finger KitKat
in the U.S our KitKat sizes come in an
obnoxious varieties of units and weights
too many to show you today see but let's
take a look at some of the biggest two
and four finger portion sizes you can
get in the UK the biggest size are the
two finger kitkats is this 21 pack all
of these add up to around 435 grams of
KitKat it's half a kilo the biggest pack
size for the four finger kitkats is a 24
pack totaling 996 grams of KitKat
basically a kilogram although
unfortunately I couldn't find that today
the UK will be stunned to learn the two
finger sizes not native to the US the
closest thing we have is our snack size
which is 7.75 grams smaller however that
being said in the US you can get a snack
size bulk bag of 66 pieces which is 916
grams and then there's the four finger
size which comes in a 36 pack and is
1512 grams okay I have a bonus to pick
with you what is with the packaging of
these new kitkats these two finger ones
had such iconic packaging in the UK it
was rats and foil and then had this band
of paper going around the outside and
now they've replaced it with plastic
bring back the old packaging
a four finger KitKat in the UK will cost
you 70p which is around 87 cents in the
US in the US one of these costs a dollar
49 or one pound twenty that's a 71 cost
increase in the US
71 more expensive in the US
that's quite rare particularly when it
comes to snacks I feel like in the UK we
tend to get stung for snacks even more
so than like fast food so hey we're
doing something right imagine if prices
of these went up by 50p in the UK
there would be riots yeah the streets
would be burning
here are all the KitKat exclusives you
can get in the US you can't get in the
UK unless of course your grocery store
has an American section pair over UK Kit
Kats you can't get in the US unless you
have access to the internet just about
every portion size that we have saved
for the four finger version the UK does
not have a closer look The Minis the
unwrapped and I want to act like this is
for sharing but like once your hand goes
in there it's yours right
also with the minions they look a lot
like your UK bites from the outside now
from what I can tell the inside of one
of these
still kind of looks like a KitKat yours
look like
almost like a Crunch bar does that make
sense let's cut the hairy where he's
just bitten inside of a bite and tell us
how it looks inside Harry
yeah
I don't know how much of this you can
see but you're not getting like the
distinct
wafer layers that you're used to from a
KitKat it's pretty much just like solid
chocolate with little pieces of a
biscuity wafer in there and stuff I'm
not quite sure what the point of the
thins are because a smaller one has less
calories but if you have a little bag of
them you're just going to eat the whole
bag right
oh God the hazelnut that's not nearly as
good as regular kick out then what's my
personal favorite range which is KitKat
chunkies firstly you can get a standard
KitKat chunky but in a Duo pack this is
just a standard unflavored KitKat chunky
but in a two pack although they're not
like full size chunky bars there's like
kind of two I guess maybe two-thirds
chunky bars so it's still bigger than a
standard one but not like an official
double now this next size we got is the
big cat and I know what all you Kit Kat
heads are saying in the UK right now
it's not the chunky your Chunky is 40
grams this one is 42 grams and it says
right here on the package five crispy
Wafers and you leave can get a close-up
on that uh that pick there that is in
fact five crispy Wafers I'm looking at
The Pick of yours online y'all got four
we got five big chunky get out of here
firstly why do you guys call these big
cats because chunky is a way better name
it's much more fun just call them KitKat
chunky and then our biggest size the XL
which from what I can tell is three Kit
Kats it's 12 pieces put the price of a
KitKat on screen then put the price of
the XL on screen is it exactly three
times maybe sending one of these to the
ocean is better than setting three
smaller ones I really don't know that
runs some of the exclusive KitKat
flavors you can find only in the UK
we'll start with this one which is a
vegan KitKat hang on
hang on a minute I've only just clocked
it vegan KitKat and then right at the
top there's a little warning label that
says may contain milk you had one job
guys I think I should do a blind taste
test Charlie has confirmed that they do
look different so my eyes are staying
closed
thank you Charlie this one feels very
like Smooth
I mean I'm already pretty sure that's
the vegan one
I'm confident this is the regular one
but this isn't bad sometimes when you
have a vegan option it's like actively
bad this one isn't offensive by any
means
was that correct yes that was correct
cool so we have four flavor options in
the UK which I believe you will not find
in the US we have a white chocolate
KitKat
it's fine I'm not the biggest white
chocolate guy an orange chocolate KitKat
foreign
a big orange chocolate fan either but
that's not bad it's like quite a subtle
orange flavor not too in your face and
here we have the caramel KitKat which I
think is new
it's pretty good I get more like
honeycomb than caramel from this
definitely sweeter than the standard
KitKat and a dark chocolate kitka
I don't normally go for dark chocolate
but I will eat it sometimes and that's
not particularly good dark chocolate
four flavors that I have seen before
that currently don't seem available
anywhere online couldn't get my hands on
them apple pie KitKat the lemon crisp
KitKat the key lime Kit Kat which is
very good and of course the birthday
cake KitKat but what I could get my hand
on are the Kit Kat Duos which are
different chocolate flavors in the top
and the bottom okay mint and dark
chocolate oh yeah look at that
look at that
broke up mocha and chocolate mocha and
chocolate let's do mocha and chocolate
oh last but not least
strawberry and dark chocolate oh look
it's kind of like my color palette
here's the best one this is the best one
the next exclusive flavor is the KitKat
chunky peanut butter these are
incredible these are one of my favorite
chocolate bars I would say in the UK
the king of chocolate bars
can we get a little crown on the KitKat
chunky peanut butter please
the next exclusive chunky flavor is the
caramel we also have this in the
standard KitKat version but let's give
the chunky one a try real quick
oh
this is very different to the two finger
Kit Kat this one has an actual layer of
caramel in it which is kind of what I
was expecting from these ones but this
one's good next up we have the KitKat
chunky white chocolate and while I
couldn't find the individual bars today
you can also get a Lotus Biscoff KitKat
chunky I was able to find this in the
form of bites so I'll give one of these
a try and give my thoughts on the flavor
I think because you get the balance of
the chocolate and a little bit of
biscuit in with the Biscoff flavoring
it's not that bad it's not overwhelming
is it enough to convince me to start
liking this golf
probably not but not bad also you can
get kit kat Sunday cones and KitKat ice
cream we have no freezer I didn't want
to Melting in the studio we actually do
have KitKat ice cream in the UK I was
able to find some in a Food Warehouse by
Iceland however I didn't buy them
because I wasn't going somewhere with a
freezer afterwards so would it be melty
and a bit of a disaster here's what they
do look like if you do find them in the
UK in the UK KitKat offers a range of
seasonal products depending on which
season you're in we're filming this in
April so we've just had Easter and they
had these adorable little KitKat bunnies
on offer this game either as a single
one
or as a little multi-pack slightly
worryingly I was able to find a
Christmas KitKat in one of the quarter
shops that I visited which apparently
these are fine until September this year
so we're fine that's quite cute actually
quite a nice little design the final
exclusive I was able to track down is a
fun one it's KitKat breakfast cereal as
the packaging suggests it's new I don't
think it's in every Supermarket or shop
yet I had to go to a waitrose to find
this they look like a
little tiny cereal pillows
I know this is not the fairest the most
accurate ways to test cereal
pretty good I was actually able to find
two of your us exclusives Joe I have the
KitKat birthday cake and the Duo's mocha
and white chocolate as many Brits will
know our high streets are plagued by
American candy stores which are these
bizarre shops which import American
snacks and chocolates and play really
loud music and I'm pretty sure are a
front for something or other but I was
finally able to benefit from them by
buying these this does have all of those
uh lovely forbidden food colorings that
we don't usually get in the UK so if I'm
really hyperactive after this we'll know
why
that's colorful
[Music]
you guys don't hold back on the sugar do
you yeah that's that's excessive that's
too much guys chill out after the
birthday cake I'm hoping for something
slightly more savory
pretty strong coffee flavor yeah this
one's fine I like this
a U.S KitKat bar is 210 calories it's 11
grams of fat 7 grams of saturated fat 20
milligrams of sodium 28 grams of carbs
23 grams of sugar and 2 grams of protein
in the UK a standard KitKat bar contains
the following 209 calories 10.2 grams of
fat of which 5.6 grams are saturated 40
milligrams of sodium 26.1 grams of carbs
of which 21.3 grams of sugars and 2.8
grams of protein that's a lesson every
category other than protein and sodium
where for some reason we have double the
US figure our most calorific KitKat is
the KitKat XL it contains a total of 640
calories in the UK our most calorific
item is a peanut butter KitKat chunky
one of these contains 226 calories which
is still less than half of the US KitKat
XL
while kitkats are now beloved all around
the world they were invented in the UK
the first modern KitKat bar was created
by the Roundtree company back in 1935
although then it was called a chocolate
crisp it wasn't until 1937 that they
first used the name KitKat renaming it
to the KitKat chocolate crisp the bar
exploded in popularity so much so that
it even survived rationing during the
second world war despite milk shortages
rather than halting production
completely the round trees changed the
recipe to use plain chocolate instead so
as not to confuse customers with the new
taste they changed the packaging to a
blue wartime color after the war when
rationing was lifted and normal
production resumed they adopted the
iconic red color that we know and love
today the popularity of KitKat continued
to grow and they were exported all over
the world in the 1970s Rountree gave
Hershey a license to manufacture and
distribute kitkats in the U.S this
agreement remained in place even after
Nestle acquired Roundtree in 1988. the
popularity of KitKat has actually turned
out to be something of a double-edged
sword for Hershey as part of that deal
with Roundtree if the company is ever
sold they lose their license to
manufacture and produce KitKat KitKat is
the single most popular products sold by
Hershey in the US so it makes it much
harder to sell the company should they
ever want to my kingdom for a KitKat
in the U.S a KitKat is made up of sugar
wheat flour cocoa butter non-fat milk
chocolate refined Palm kernel oil
lactose milk milk fat and contains two
percent or less of soy lecithin pgpr
which is an emulsifier yeast artificial
flavor salt and sodium bicarbonate a UK
KitKat has the following ingredients
sugar wheat flour which contains Calcium
iron thiamin and niacin milk powders
whole and skimmed cocoa Mass cocoa
butter vegetable fats lactose and
proteins from whey whey powder
emulsifier sunflower lecithin yeast
raising agent sodium bicarbonate butter
fat and natural flavorings if you've
seen the Snickers episode you might
remember that in the UK we tend to feel
our chocolate is of a higher quality
than that found in the U.S it's
generally a bit richer and a bit
smoother the reason for this is a higher
cocoa and fat content found in our
chocolate according to UK rules
chocolate must contain no less than 25
cocoa solids to be considered milk
chocolate the milk used in each
country's KitKat production also differs
slightly in the UK Nestle uses milk
crumb which is a dehydrated slightly
sweetened milk product in the U.S
Hershey uses non-fat milk and milk fat
and in the U.S the rules are our milk
chocolate must contain no less than 10
of chocolate liqueur which is roughly
equal part mix of Coca salads and cocoa
butter unlike most U.S chocolates like
Snickers for instance our kitkats do
contain sugar and not high fructose corn
syrup really
yeah it's worth pointing out that in the
UK kitkats are made by Nestle while in
the U.S they're made by Hershey
furthermore in 2015 Hershey did a deal
with let's buy British Imports to stop
importing all Cadbury's chocolate made
overseas and in the same deal agreed to
Halt Imports of so many British
chocolates like KitKat also and this can
be for another episode the license
agreement allows Hershey to make for
example Cadbury chocolate in the U.S
with the same packaging as in the UK but
with a different recipe
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Costco food and the US and the
UK this is food for us
here is an iconic Costco hot dog in the
UK ah yes the famous
Costco hot dog in the UK the length of a
hot dog is
eight inches don't laugh
eight inches almost exactly eight inch
dug it's also advertised as of course a
pound of hot dog let's see if that's
true
so with the bun and some onions the
whole thing weighs 250 grams I'm going
to take the sausage out and wear that on
its own to see if that is a quarter
pounder turns out that without the bun
and the toppings it does weigh exactly a
quarter of a pound that's pretty
impressive I know it's like manufactured
and mass made by machines but you know
still cool oh my God it's exactly four
ounces
wow they kept it a quarter pound after
it's cooked and everything see Costco
it's not impossible all these people
watch this and they're like it's a
quarter of pound before you cook it well
they said four ounces whatever they're
doing after it's cooked it is the
advertised four ounces way to go Costco
in the UK a Costco pizza is 17 inches in
diameter that makes the surface area 227
square inches in the U.S our Costco
pizza should also be 18 inches in
diameter let's measure it it more like
17 and a half Costco it's still 9.99
that's a ridiculous deal you can keep
that half an inch
a pizza today was cut into six pieces
I'd say for a pizza of this size it's
kind of uncommon to see only six slices
I would expect maybe eight or ten like a
dominoes but we're gonna weigh one slice
and find out how big it is now let's
weigh one slice
that is a dense slice of pizza there's
some citation needed but this might be
the heaviest slice of pizza we've ever
weighed on food Wars that's a big layer
of cheese not a ton of tomato sauce I
would say it's like maybe 70 bread so I
don't know if you're getting a ton of
value for money when it comes to
toppings
I quite like it
it's got that nostalgic cheap frozen
pizza quality the chicken bake
I don't know what the origin of this is
but it's pretty good idea it's like a
giant chicken hot pocket right
the guy holding up the fish face just
caught we've already used this gag in a
recent episode but we can reuse it
I am curious
well why is this so good this is so good
I will say I love stodgy food
so I feel like I am the target audience
for all of these Foods the fountain
drinks in the UK come in one size and
it's supposedly 22 fluid ounces of
course we have to check it
so in what seems to be an increasingly
rare occurrence on food Wars that is
actually as much drink as we were
promised that's 22 ounces but Mountain
drinks in the U.S are 20 fluid ounces
look at it it's exactly 20 ounces and I
filled it up at the thing now Costco is
like razor sharp with the portions right
they're not leaving anything the chance
thank you Costco
here are all the Costco menu items in
the UK that you won't find in the US
the US you won't find in the UK quick
disclaimer that the menu seem to vary
slightly depending on where you are in
the UK or the US I got these from the
chingford location just outside of
London and Joe's got his from the
Burbank location in California we have
one exclusive Pizza option in the UK
from Costco and it's this one the
barbecue chicken pizza as the name
suggests it's a barbecue chicken pizza
which also comes with some green bell
peppers and some red onion when I see a
barbecue Pizza in the UK I usually
Grimace because it tends to mean that
the sauce is barbecue and I don't like
that but I think here they've actually
just kept the same like cheese and
tomato base but out of the barbecue
toppings on top which in my opinion is
what a barbecue Pizza should be
Leon does not agree it still feels
pretty hefty maybe not quite as dense or
as Hefty as the cheese pizza did the
dough seems to be not quite as thick try
to Twisted Chicken on its own first
it's not bad I'm not getting much
barbecue flavor from that
it's more just like a sort of grilled
chicken
usually my biggest complaint of barbecue
pizzas is a two barbecue whereas this
one actually isn't very barbecue at all
that means that I like it but if you do
normally like quite a strong barbecue
sauce flavor from your pizzas this one
might not be enough for you in the UK
you can also get whole pizzas as part of
a family bundle the bundles come with a
full-size Pizza one of these gigantic
garlic breads
two of these garlic and herb dips
and also a two liter bottle of Pepsi Max
half of which I have spilled on the
floor of the studio
Twisted churro we have these you guys
don't that's not a lot of stuff all
right first thing churro cinnamon dough
next up we've got Costco is take on a
classic British dish
cottage pie now our American viewers may
have heard of shepherd's pie cottage pie
is basically the same thing and it's a
layer of some cheese on top usually some
mashed potato but instead of the Lamb
mince mixture cottage pie contains beef
mince now this is a classic British dish
and we do feel pretty passionately about
things like this so let's hope Costco
have done it justice the strategy seems
to be sell large quantities of food
but really pack it with the kind of
cheap stuff so for example there's like
a small amount of cheese on top here a
very small amount of beef on the bottom
and I'd say like 80 of this it's just
mashed potato let's give it a try
it's actually quite tasty
it's I'm not
I don't work for Costco I just I'm a
truth Seeker so again the beef is like
it's very rich it's quite thick
but there's a real like meaty flavor to
that is it the best cottage pie you've
ever had no probably not but is it like
an affordable filling version that's
fairly true to to the original
I'd have to kind of say yeah you do get
100 more filling as you go into the
middle as well it wasn't all like that
thankfully
yeah I don't know I actually don't think
they've done too bad a job here next up
we have this one which is the double
chicken fillet sandwich considering the
theme of just like Hefty Foods this
thing is absolutely massive
it yeah I think maybe they were supposed
to stack the chicken patties instead of
lay them side by side because the bun
barely covers any of it they've also
only put one slice of cheese on it so
only about 40 of it is covered in cheese
I might have to do some quick tactical
rearrangement here oh there's maybe
there's another bit of cheese on the
bottom so you get cheese
but then it's like can you eat this
because that is also a logistical
nightmare to eat I think whichever way
you stack this it's going to be quite
tricky to eat but this is the double
chicken fillet sandwich there are two
chicken fillets two slices of cheese
some lettuce and some tomato
extremely dry
very Bland like none of the components
Taste of anything somehow it's a bit of
a miss again it's like it's big
it would fill you up next up we have the
Korean barbecue beef bake so it's like
the chicken bacon that it's kind of a
baguette with some cheese on top filled
with meat but instead of chicken and
bacon this one has Korean barbecue beef
I imagine it's going to be a similar
level of stodginess to the chicken bake
and also to everything else that we've
eaten today the filling on its own
doesn't really taste of much which is
slightly disappointing
that's Bland that's disappointing I'm
still eating it but it's planned
just like nothing that jumps out to me
is like you know Korean flavors in this
if you're going to make something that
bland I think don't drag your ear
through the mud just call it a beef bake
and be done with it there's one other
classic British dish on the UK Costco
menu which Unfortunately they forgot to
give me today and it's jacket potatoes
there's a note in the script where Joe
says that he doesn't know what a jacket
potato is so I'll do my best to just
explain it to you now as the name
suggests it's basically just a potato
that you keep in your jacket in case you
get hungry these can either be boiled or
baked you'll usually wrap it in some
foil just so that it doesn't kind of
touch anything else that's in your
pockets keep it on you and then whenever
you get hungry during the day you have a
nice snack with you as the name suggests
it's basically a potato that you keep in
your jacket
we also have two exclusive dessert style
options in the UK including a caramel
fudge sundae and a Coffee caramel frappe
I didn't get either of them today but
here's what they look like
[Music]
two
cold drinks
you get here in the U.S Costco is the
fruit smoothie
oh my God that's great
um
well it's really good
and the cold brew mocha freeze
homeboy has melted I'm not I'm really
surprised how good these cold drinks are
I mean the food is good but these are
really good
yeah that's picking me up that's picking
me up Yules let's go
ah now I need to
calm down a little bit
and finally in the UK we also have mango
smoothies on the menu although today
that machine was broken they weren't
serving them here's what they look like
want to take this moment to talk about
Kirkland Costco's signature brand that
provides a wide variety of products for
a low cost over the years the brand has
developed a loyal fan base among Costco
members it would be impossible to
feature of the Kirkland food and
beverage items exclusive to the US not
in the UK and believe me I begged
management to let me sample Kirkland's
many alcohol options to which they said
no way so here are a few non-alcohol
Kirkland Signature favorite exclusives
in the US I'm gonna start here animal
crackers I mean come on UK and who
doesn't love animal crackers are animal
crackers popular in the United Kingdom
oh my God Let's do let's do the animal
review I think monkey uh gorilla
orangutan this looks like a hippo
we got hippo oh this is most certainly a
koala so I've seen that guy already
we're already getting repeats alligator
I think possibly a dragon
a Brookfield Zoo all on your fingertips
here on cracker form fantastic in the
U.S is not playing with their cheese
selection so many and the one according
to the internet that just everyone is
raving about is a course the parmigiano
riggiano
one and a half pounds how much do you
think a one and a half pound block of
parmigiano Reggiano costs go
what do you think
actually it was 16 geez
everyone's gonna be like fifty dollars
no 16 that's still really good 16 bucks
for all this I mean this is gonna last
man this will last many of your uh wine
and cheese parties uh and of course
Costco has a fantastic selection of wine
all of which I'm not allowed to go near
apparently according to management
all right give this video a lot more
entertaining we were doing the wine
review peanut butter peanut butter
peanut butter when I went to the UK I'm
not kidding you every person I talk to
when they realized I was an American
which was literally one second after I
opened my mouth they all asked me the
same thing what is with Americans and
peanut butter is peanut butter not
popular in the UK they were like you
guys you guys put peanut butter and
everything they kind of do
this is really good peanut butter please
forgive me all the peanut butter heads
watching do you want it this liquidy
because I'm thinking peanut butter
sandwiches peanut butter and jelly
peanut butter and honey whatever you're
mixing the peanut butter with right you
want some thickness to it to stay on the
bread do we want thin peanut butter I
don't know I'm asking you as a viewer
what is the preferred viscosity of
peanut butter I mean this is creamy
but I mean like
cream creamy Italian sparkling mineral
water with carbonation added if anyone
was wondering just how boring I am
my favorite sparkling water is actually
the
non-flavored
right like Lacroix my favorite ones the
the plain that's right you better Ugg I
just like I like the bubbles in the
water
hmm
smells Italian
[Music]
oh yeah it's like really harsh this is
very good
mm-hmm
like I want that harshness of the
bubbles what are you illing about
speaking of Italy
pesto so the basil is important I don't
think this was made in Italy basil
people swear by this stuff they swear by
it
dried mango slices this way here look
how many of these they gave me man this
is two and a half pounds
dried organic mango slices I am a mango
boy
that's an impressive list of stuff we
don't have that many Kirkland exclusives
in the UK but there is one interesting
one I found which is this hazelnut
spread this is just Costco's version of
Nutella not Nutella well that was
interesting because I was looking at the
ingredients of this and the percentages
kind of pique my interest so of Interest
we Google what the contents of real
Nutella and the ingredients said that
there were 13 real hazelnuts in there as
well as 7.4 fat reduced cocoa powder so
if we compare it to this one
Leon how much do you think how much
hazelnut do you think is in this
13 percent what to say exactly the same
fat reduced cocoa powder 7.4 so on paper
this has basically identical ingredients
to real Nutella it smells and looks a
lot like Nutella
I would struggle to tell this apart from
realnessella in a blind taste test and
it is cheaper so hey
next time you're around and you really
really love Nutella you can buy it in
bulk here and you won't really know I
also found some products which weren't
Kirkland brown but did pique my interest
I found this kind of catering sized tub
of Marmite which I could not resist I
assume this is an exclusive and not
something that you'd find in the US not
100 sure made Marmite pasta and put it
on Instagram yesterday and people got
upset so
it felt relevant then I also found some
American products at Costco that you
wouldn't normally see on British shelves
for example Skippy brand peanut butter
this isn't bad but like
so much oil in here you can see it's
like running off the top and it's kind
of made the whole thing of very liquidy
according to the ingredients this is 10
hydrogenated palm oil
which might go somewhere to explaining
why it's so liquidy at room temperature
these caught my eye while I was browsing
the shelves Smuckers Goober neither of
those are real words first of all
but this is peanut butter and grape
jelly stripes is this what Americans are
putting in PB and J's they claims to be
America's favorite combination peanut
butter and jelly how much competition do
they have in this field I'd love to know
Americans love grape flavor things and
it's really not common in the UK for
whatever reason it's quite pretty I'd
love to see the machine that puts this
into the jar in that pattern
this is a lot more solid I think they've
added like gelling agents and stuff to
this to keep it in that uniform shape
with the cool color pattern the grape
jelly is extremely sweet and the peanut
butter even I think on its own is quite
sweet compared to the Skippy as well I
want to give a disclaimer this is the
exclusive sections I don't think these
are exclusive I just know now one
awesome thing about the Costco here in
the US I don't know if it's in the UK
here you can confirm this is they have
ridiculously good baked goods Costco's
in the US is also famous for having a
sheet cake couldn't get it you got to
order it ahead of time I'm sorry let's
get a picture of that on the screen
with my face on it
but they have so many muffins and
croissants and other things I heard
really good things about the bakery
section at Costco so I also had to give
that a try
this goes out to katya's Dad our
producer Katya apparently her dad really
loves Costco croissant I feel like these
would benefit significantly from being
heated up it's not bad as far as like
pre-packaged and finally these cookies
get chocolate chip
double chocolate and white chocolate
in the UK a lot of our like pre-packaged
cookies for whatever reason tend to be
really solid and you can like Snap them
rather than chew them but this is the
much softer American style cookie which
is really good full disclosure this is
the first time I've ever shopped at a
Costco and that's not a snap thing see I
grew up my dad worked for a grocery
chain and then I move out into the world
and the thought of having a case of
toilet paper or bottled water in my
shoebox apartment was crazy also sixty
dollars for a membership I mean I was
just scraping by so come with sixty
dollars to go grocery shopping was
Madness for me so and then just never um
never went until now for this video and
I think Costco is really awesome I like
it now shout out to Kirkland Costco in
the UK is a little bit weird because not
just anyone can actually walk into a
Costco you have to actually apply for
warehouse membership which is different
to just standard online membership and
to do that you have to be working in a
certain number of limited professions
some of the professions make sense it's
things like teachers who maybe work in
school and to buy suppliers and some of
them are really random things like
Airline workers are allowed in I think I
was technically allowed in as a
journalist so this is journalism if
anyone asks I believe a year of standard
individual membership cost around 30
pounds maybe slightly more there's
different tiers as well you can get like
executive membership where you unlock
certain perks honestly I don't really
know why it's set up exactly this way in
the UK I guess they want to kind of have
some control over the foot traffic in
the stores they don't want everybody
just piling into the store I went at
11AM on a Tuesday and it was really busy
and I asked someone on the till and they
said that that wasn't even busy by their
standards I think this is what it's like
in the US but the shop itself was just
basically an enormous Warehouse with
stuff everywhere it wasn't organized
hugely well the aisles weren't
particularly sort of labeled there were
numbers on the RS but didn't say what
was in them so I just kind of had to
like snake around and try and find what
I could find things were slightly
cheaper in there than usual but I don't
even think things were like massively
discounted particularly the Branded
stuff compared to the Kirkland stuff so
I think you're more just going because
you need to buy things in bulk and it's
like more convenient rather than because
you're trying to save a lot of money on
your day-to-day groceries for me to be
able to sign up for this they needed to
see a pay slip so they could prove who I
was employed by kind of weird
foreign pizza from a UK Costco will cost
you 9 pounds 99 which at the time of
recording was 12.38 a Costco Pizza in
the US is 9.95 or 8 pounds three Pence
that's a 19.9 price decrease in the US
the Costco hot dog here in the US with a
20 ounce soda is 1.50 the same price
it's been since 1985. how has Costco
managed to sell them for so low for all
these years in an hyc meeting everything
has been hit by inflation the Costco hot
dog has become somewhat of a viral
phenomenon the commitment to keeping the
hot dog combo at 1.50 is so strong that
as The Story Goes when the current CEO
approached the old CEO about possibly
raising the price he said if you raise
the price of the hot dog I will kill you
figure it out and they did Costco would
soon switch from selling Hebrew national
hot dogs in their food courts to
manufacturing their own they open a hot
dog Factory in La then in Chicago
reducing production costs and keeping
the hot dog at the dollar fifty price
point today it is fair to point out that
our hot dog costs 1 pound 50 which is
more like 1.86 it does come with two
more ounces of soda so maybe that's why
or maybe Costco just likes the aesthetic
of having 150 on the site
a slice of pepperoni pizza from a UK
Costco is 826 calories while a slice of
cheese pizza is 751. the most calorific
thing on the menu is a whole pepperoni
pizza a whole pepperoni pizza is
4962 calories which is 248 of your daily
allowance a slice of pepperoni at Costco
in the U.S is 650 calories a slice of
cheese roughly the same size would be
710 calories that's 60 calories more hmm
does that make sense that the cheese is
more calories than the pepperoni I got
it I got it
wow the UK chicken bake is 911 calories
an entire U.S chicken bake is 840
calories
a UK hot dog is 602 calories the hot dog
and 20 ounce soda in the U.S is 582 850
calories depending on the drink you get
so at least calories would be of course
a Diet Pepsi which has zero calories if
you got a regular Pepsi that'd be 250
calories and if you want to get the most
calories in your drink that of course
would be 280 extra calories if you've
got the Tropicana fruit punch I've been
asked by my producer to wipe up the
crumbs one thing Little Caesars didn't
provide were napkins that's okay let me
wipe my mouth real quick
this video
sponsored by Domino's
she's ah at two Brute